l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la motion de censure déposée en
application de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la Constitution par Madame Mathilde
Panau et 77 membres de l'Assemblée la
première ministre ayant engagé la
responsabilité du Gouvernement sur
l'adoption de la 2e partie et l'ensemble
du projet de loi de finances pour
2024 je donne donc la parole à Monsieur
Antoine léomand pour le groupe la
francemise
commence pas
monsieur madame la présidente mesdames
et messieurs les ministres chers
collègues madame la Première ministre
dégager dégager du balai dehors ça
suffit voilà ce que nous vous disons
avec notre motion de censure voilà ce
que vous disent avec nous des millions
de Français qui chantent Macron
démission partez madame la Première
ministre car vous abîmez la France et sa
république vous en avez encore fait la
démonstration il y a 2 jours avec votre
16e 493 nos compatriotes doivent savoir
comment ça s'est passé car vous avez
transformé l'Assemblée nationale en
théâtre de marionnette je vous raconte
la pièce 23h40 la séance est suspendu on
va changer de décor vous entrez dans
l'hémicycle avec un grand sourire on
change de présidente de séance tout est
en place pour la pièce de théâtre à 23h
48 ça commence la présidente de
l'Assemblée vous convoque à la tribune
elle se marre le public des marionnettes
macronistes se lève et applaudit à tout
rompre sa propre mise à mort
parlementaire puis vous parlez triomphal
s de votre force vous connaissez votre
texte par cœur puisque vous l'avez déjà
fait 15 fois sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement blab blabla à 23h52 4
minutes plus tard c'est déjà fini fin de
la pièce rideau applaudissement des
marionnettes vous ne faites même plus
semblant d'en avoir quelque chose à
faire vous écrabouillez l'Assemblée
nationale en 4 minutes chrono avec un
grand sourire vous piétinz le Parlement
et vous vous en amusez pour vous c'est
devenu un jeu rien de plus mais ce n'est
pas un
jeu ce n'est pas un jeu madame la
Première ministre car vous détruisez la
France en détruisant sa
République la France n'est pas une
entreprise les Français ne sont pas vos
salariés et vous n'êtes pas leur
patronne c'est l'inverse la France est
une République le souverain c'est le
peuple le patron c'est lui les employés
c'est nous et la fonction qu'il nous a
confié c'est de servir l'intérêt
général ce n'est pas un jeu c'est un
devoir mais vous riez car ce soir vous
dormirez au chaud et le ventre plein
pourtant d'autres n'auront pas cette
chance 2000 personnes meurent dans la
rue et de la rue chaque année un
Français sur 10 ne mange pas à sa fin un
Français sur 5 finit le moi découvert
330000 personnes sont sans domicile fixe
2800 enfants dorment dans la rue voilà
votre bilan comment faites-vous pour
dormir le soir tout en sachant que 2800
enfants meurent dans la rue si j'étais à
votre place si j'étais à votre place
madame la Première ministre moi ça
m'empêcherait de dormir si j'étais à
votre place je mettrais tous les moyens
de l'État pour faire en sorte qu'aucun
enfant ne dorme dans la rue ce soir mais
non vous faites des 493 pour les riches
oh je sais que vous détestez l'inventeur
de notre devise nationale liberté
égalité fraternité pourtant écoutez-le
Maximilien Robespierre disait nul ne
peut entasser des monceaux de blé à côté
de son semblable qui meurent de faim je
vous ai parlé de ceux qui meurent de
faim voici ceux qui entassent les
monceaux de blé comme jamais depuis
l'élection de Macron en 2017 Bernard
Arnaud plus 156 milliards en 6 ans
famille Hermes plus 107 milliards
famille béancour plus 41 milliards d'un
côté ceux qui ont tout de l'autre ceux
qui n'ont rien et au milieu de tout cela
la masse des gens qui travaillent pour
des salaires de misère se cassent le dos
sont sous antidépresseur ne voi pas
assez leurs gosses ne savent pas comment
payer les factures du mois suivant la
masse de ceux qui bossent et qui
pourtant
galèrent
depuis cette tribune qui devrait être
celle où s'exprime la voix du peuple et
non des riches je dis bravo et merci à
celles et ceux qui tiennent notre pays
debout quelle que soit leur nationalité
qu'ils soit avec ou sans papier ouvrier
du bâtiment et de l'industrie
agriculteur employés de bureau agent
d'entretien enseignant chauffeur routier
aide soignante aide à domicile serveur
cuisinier secrétaire caissiè vendeur
manutentionnaire coiffeur livreur
étudiants bravo et merci à ceux qui
tiennent debout un pays que vous voulez
mettre à genou madame la Première
ministre mais vous n'y arriverez pas car
ici c'est la France notre peuple est
rebelle et insoumis il ne courbe jamais
les chines et ne baisse jamais les yeux
madame la Première ministre je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure que vous détruisiez
la France en détruisant la République
laissez-moi vous en dire plus qu'est-ce
que la République c'est le gouvernement
du peuple par le peuple et pour le
peuple quelle est sa devise Liberté
Égalité Fraternité au j'inventent rien
j'ai seulement lu l'article 2 de la
Constitution et tandis que vous avez
trouvé le moyen de citer 16 fois
l'article 493 cette tribune vous n'avez
toujours pas appliquer cet article 2 qui
pourtant vous oblige vous faites
l'inverse Macron gouverne seul contre le
peuple et pour les riches avec vos 493 à
répétition vous faites pire que Louis X
car la Constitution de 1791 donnait au
roi un DRP de vé qui ne s'appliquait pas
sur les questions budgétaires et vous
vous 493 493 493 vous ne savez pas faire
de budget sans acte d'autorité vous
faites pire que Louis X mais des gilets
jaunes en révolte de juin des
soulèvements de la terre aux
manifestations spontanées contre la
réforme des retraites à 64 ans le peuple
français des tours et des Bours n' cess
de vous rappeler qu'il est insoumis
rebelle et révolutionnaire votre
couronne tient toujours certes mais elle
finira par tomber comme toutes les
autres avant la vôtre alors la 6e
république adviendra alors constituante
adviendra alors le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne adviendra la 5e
République a 65 ans il est temps qu'elle
prenne sa retraite et vous votre congé
avec notre motion de
censure liberté égalité fraternité où
est la liberté quand le droit manifesté
est sans cesse menacé quand on ne peut
perdre un œil pour avoir dit Macron
démission quand on peut se faire mettre
en garde à vue pour avoir défendu la
planète et la retraite quand on peut
perdre la moitié du crâne parce qu'on
s'appelle Edie ou la vie parce qu'on
s'appelle naë quand on peut se prendre
une amende de 135 € pour avoir dit cessz
le feu à Gaza madame la Première
ministre quand nous avons fondé la
première République en 1793 nous avons
écrit dans notre Constitution que le
droit à manifester ne pouvait être
interdit et que s'il était c'était la
présence du despotisme la République
vous juge madame la Première ministre
revoilà le
despotisme où est l'égalité quand les
riches ont tout et que les autres n'ont
rien j'en ai parlé j'ai dit ce que vous
faites je dis ce qu'il faut faire
augmenter les salaires et porter le SMIC
à 1600 € bloquer les prix des produits
de première nécessité faire laallocation
d'autonomie à 1100 € pour les jeunes
augmenter les retraites à 1600 € par
mois pour une carrière complète et
porter le minimum vieillesse à 1100 €
par mois enfin où est la fraternité
quand vous montez sans arrêt les
Français les uns contre les autres les
travailleurs contre les chômeurs les
retraités contre les travailleurs les
banlieusards contre les compagnards les
Français contre les immigrés les vieux
contre les jeunes où est la fraternité
quand vous êtes incapable de lutter
contre le racisme qui s'exprime partout
dans notre société quand vous êtes
incapable de le nommer dès lors que
celui qui en est responsable porte un
uniforme quand vous êtes incapable de
défendre une laïcité qui soit autre
chose que l'expression d'une haine de
moins en moins voilée contre les
musulmans quand vous êtes incapable de
mettre fin aux actes antisémites et
d'avoir une parole forte pour faire cess
ceux qui ont lieu en ce moment quand
vous courez après l'extrême droite et
que vous vous apprêtez à marcher avec
elle au moment où il faudrait au
contraire la combattre pour la faire
reculer dans la poubelle d'où elle est
de nouveau sortie je vous dis tout ceci
madame la Première ministre un jour pas
comme les autres car nous sommes la nuit
du 9 au 10 novembre 2023 car il y a 85
ans c'était la nuit de cristal dans
l'Allemagne Nazi car il y a ce soir avec
nous les fantômes de ceux qui sont morts
cette nuitl parce qu'ils étaient juifs
car pèse sur nous les 6 millions de
regards éteint par Hitler mais dont
l'intense lumière transperse encore et à
jamais la nuit et le brouillard pour
arriver jusqu'à nous je vous le dis
madame la Première ministre les yeux
dans les yeux je le dis à tous les
républicains qui sont ici les yeux dans
les yeux ne vous trompez pas d'ennemis
n'oubliez pas le passé n'inventez pas le
racisme et l'antisémitisme là où il
n'existe pas et où ils n'ont jamais
existé combattez-le plusutôt là où il a
existé où il existe encore et où il
existera
toujours pour notre part nous savons ce
que nous faisons et nous savons où nous
allons nous sommes humanistes et
républicains nous combattons le racisme
et
l'antisémitisme nous défendons la paix
civile et la justice sociale nous
chantons la Marseillaise dans
l'hémicycle quand vous faites un 493
contre les retraites nous portons
fièrement le drapeau tricolore de la
République né d'une révolution en
1789 nous disons liberté égalité
fraternité et nous en avons fait un
programme de gouvernement avec l'avenir
en commun bref nous
sommes nous
sommes bref nous sommes comme les
canusement s'il vous plaît nous savons
PL que le règne du peuple arrivera quand
votre règne
finira seront le linceul du vieux monde
car on entend déjà la révolte qui gronde
madame la Première ministre dégage on
sait quoi faire pour vous
remplacer la parole est à Madame
Véronique louvagi pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la la
présidente madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues nous nous retrouvons de
nouveau ce jeudi pour examiner une
nouvelle et 1è motion de censure déposée
par Mathilde Panau et ses collègues de
la France insoumise pour la 16e fois
depuis votre arrivée à Matignon vous
avez mardi soir Madame la première
ministre activer l'article 49 alignéa 3
de la Constitution sur la seconde partie
et l'ensemble du projet de loi de
finances pour 2024 il est vrai que
l'utilisation du 493 devient une triste
habitude depuis le début de ce mandat en
17 mois vous l'avez déjà activé sur six
projets de lois différents le PLF 2023
le PLFSS 2023 le PLFSS rectificatif qui
correspondait à la réforme des retraites
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques le PLF 2024 et le PLFSS
2024 et comme à chaque fois la France
insoumise dépose dans la foulée une
motion de censure et je bien à chaque
fois du côté des républicains en dépit
de nos réelles divergences avec le
gouvernement nous savons que pour
fonctionner la France a besoin de se
doter d'un budget et d'une loi de
sécurité sociale avant le 31 décembre de
chaque année et donc avant le 31
décembre 2023 je l'ai toujours dit
monsieur le ministre ne soyons donc pas
DUP de l'hypocrisie de la France
insoumise sur ce point nous déplorons ce
recours massif à l'article
493 surtout quand il nous prive de débat
mais pour autant les députés et les
républicains resteront une opposition
responsable car l'intérêt du pays
demeure notre boussole nous ne voterons
donc pas cette motion de censure et nous
ne rentrerons pas dans le jeu dangereux
du groupe LFI et je n'ai aucun regret
sur les propos que je vais avoir quand
je viens d'entendre monsieur léomand un
jeu dangereux dans lequel les députés du
rassemblement national sont d'ailleurs
vos alliés objectifs pour mener ensemble
la politique du pire depuis 1 an depuis
un an avec le rassemblement national
vous vous toiseer du regard devant les
caméras mais vous vous faites
régulièrement des clin d'œil quand il
s'agit d'unir vos votes vous vous
confondé par ailleurs dans une
compétition victimaire alors que vous
connaissez pertinemment les règles du
jeu parlementaire je voudrais ici
dénoncer vos incohérences les
incohérences de la France insoumis
d'abord vous justifiez votre motion de
censure parce que je l'ai lu en
indiquant que le gouvernement et je vous
cite refuse aux élus de la nation le
droit de débattre et je pourrait vous
suivre là-dessus sauf que dans le même
temps mes chers collègues vous déposez
des motions de rejet sur ces textes qui
si elles étaient adopté nous priverait
justement de débat dans l'hémicycle en
somme c'est faites ce que je dis mais ne
faites pas ce que je fais ensuite vous
dénoncez le 493 en considérant que
chacune de ces utilisations est et je
vous cite encore une fois une nouvelle
étape dans la pente autoritaire dévalé
par le gouvernement mais vous ne
disposez ici d'aucune majorité absolue
pour faire adopter un budget et
heureusement d'ailleurs heureusement
surtout vous acceptez derrière une
apparente hostilité sans rechigner et
dans le plus grand silence les voix du
rassemblement national qui votent la
main sur le cœur vos motions de censure
et vous ne vous vous ne trouvez rien à y
redire car vous avez intérêt à vous unir
entre extrême et à surfer main dans la
main dans une dangereuse démagogie enfin
sur le fond à la nupess votre
contrebudget c'est plus d'impôts encore
des impôts et toujours des impôts là
encore vous défendez la même ligne que
le rassemblement national et souvent
d'ailleurs les mêmes impôts avec le
rassemblement national je pense
notamment à vos projets communs de taxes
sur les surprofit vous refusez de voir
que notre pays croule sous les
prélèvements obligatoires dont il est
devenu le champion d'Europe incontesté
chez les républicains notre ADN c'est la
diminution des impôts la diminution des
cotisations la diminution des taxes la
diminu des prélèvements dont nous avons
fait la matrice de notre contrebudget
cessons de plomber le pouvoir d'achat
des familles et la compétitivité des
entreprises par une fiscalité aussi
excessive sur la forme ensuite je
dénonce certaines méthodes de la France
insoumise et en particulier les
manœuvres incessantes que vous avez
opéré pour faire changer en permanence
vos députés de commission en raison de
ce dévoiement des switch entre
commissions les habituels commissaires
aux finances se sont vu privés de tant
de par
par des députés qui n'appartiennent pas
à notre commission car oui pour pouvoir
terminer à temps l'exécution des
missions il fallait légitimement limiter
les prises de parole en commission vous
avez par ailleurs multiplié les
amendements de crédit qui sont autant
d'amendements de dépenses cette démesure
que disje cette open bar sur les
amendements a conduit la commission des
finances à devoir mettre fin à l'examen
de la mission autremire car nous avions
consommé l'intégralité des crédits et ce
sont les les autres groupes beaucoup
plus raisonnables sur le nombre
d'amendements déposés qui n'avaient
ensuite même plus la latitude de
défendre leurs amendements restants
incomble en séance nous sommes arrivés à
la situation ubesque où le rapporteur de
la mission outrem est venu à retirer
certains de ses propres amendements
pourtant voter en commission des
finances et comme un rapporteur ne peut
retirer un amendement de la commission
il a alors demandé à ses collègues
députés nupes de voter contre leurs
propres amendements pour éviter des
épuiser tous les crédits de la mission
un véritable sketch j'ajoute au passage
que certains amendements dépassaient la
dizaine de milliards d'euros je vous le
dis madame pano mais vous le lui direz
vous avez participé très largement très
largement à une déresponsabilisation des
députés dans cet hémicycle avec en fait
un seul objectif et monsieur léomand
nous l'a encore montré il y a quelques
instant focaliser laattention sur vous
faire le buzz cristalliser les tensions
et vous nous l'avez redit et faire de
cet hémicycle une scène de théâtre mais
tout ce jeu de dupe est en train de vous
rendre inaudible et de conforter voire
de renforcer le gouvernement qui brille
pourtant par ses renoncements et ses
échecs en matière de gestion des
finances car la faute originelle vient
bien sûr du gouvernement qui confine les
députés chez eux avec ce déluge de
493 le 493 est une faculté
constitutionnelle pour éviter un vote il
ne doit surtout pas devenir un outil
pour vous exonérer de débat pour nous
priver de débat et pour priver également
les Français de débat une telle attitude
est dangereuse car en dévitalisant la
vie de l'Assemblée nationale en vidant
d'un trait de plume des semaines entière
du calendrier parlementaire en
démobilisant les députés vous alimentez
leur frustration vous crispez les
Français et vous souffle sur les braises
de leur colère mais madame Panau vous
n'étiez pas obligé de sauter si
systématiquement dans le piège qui vous
est tendu avec toutes vos motions de
censure dont aucune ne sera adoptée vous
les banalisez vous en affaiblissez la
portée vous accréditez la dangereusité
d'un parlement qui ne compte plus tout
cela ne fait que des perdants notre
démocratie s'en trouve abîmée et les
Français s'en rendent compte un habitant
de ma circonscription pourtant
macroniste de la première heure
m'indiqué il y a quelques jours que ce
qu'il retient de ce mandat du Président
de la République et la manière dont la
démocratie s'est abîmée c'est peut dire
et c'est particulièrement grave
rendez-vous compte madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres nous n'aurons aucunement
débattu de sujet majeur je n'en citerai
que quelquesuns mais il y en a plein
d'autres nous n'avons pas pu parler du
régime fiscal particulièrement
accommodant pour la trentaine des
fédérations sportive internationale
reconnu par le Comité international
olympique à quelques mois des Joos de
Paris c'est pourtant passé au travers un
amendement au projet de loi de finances
2024 déposé en catimini mercredi 18
octobre par les députés Renaissance dont
le rapporteur général de la commission
des finances nous n'avons pas pu parler
des crédits de ma prime renve dont nous
avons découvert il y a quelques jours
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finances de fin de gestion 2023 une
sous-exécution majeure conduisant à une
annulation de crédit de 1,1 milliards
cela n'est pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu
et alors que la communication
gouvernementale du 12 octobre dernier
évoqué je cite un effort pour financer
la rénovation énergétique des logements
portant à 5 milliard d'euros le budget
total qui sera consacré l'année
prochaine on est finalement loin du
compte nous n'avons pas pu parler des
risques de contentieux de l'article 15
de la loi de finance qui prévoit une
taxation des concessions d'autoroute
avec une extension des aéroports comment
les risques de contention ont-ils été
apprécié ce sont autant de questions qui
n'ont pas trouvé de réponse faute
d'avoir pu les soulever nous n'avons pas
non plus évoqué la situation très
alarmante du logement pourtant tous les
voyants sont au rouge en matière de
construction tout cela est bien désolant
même si je veux retenir les quelques
avancées obtenues par les députés les
républicains sur des sujets comme la
recherche sur les la maladie de l'IME la
recherche contre les cancers
pédiatriques l'indemnisation des
victimes de la dépquine la
revalorisation des aides financières
individuelles au pupilles de la nation
ou encore la prolongation de l'exp
entation mieux reconstruire après les
inondations comme je vous l'ai dit nous
ne voterons pas cette motion de censure
car primo notre pays se doit d'avoir un
budget et aucun consensus ici ne permet
d'y aboutir et ce condo la vision des
républicains est aux antipodes de celle
affiché par la France insoumise et ce
soir encore je vous
remercie merci Madame
louvagi la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Blanchet pour le groupe
démocrate modem et indépendant
[Applaudissements]
merci
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers
collègues le président de mon groupe
Jean-Paul Matth et mes deux chers
collègues Nicolas turquis et ha Luquet
ayant déjà évoqué devant vous lors des
trois dernières semaines ce que nous
pensions de la faculté de des
oppositions à fourbir des motions de
censure je vais me permettre ce soir de
dériver un peu au-delà de l'utilisation
du
493 parce que nous le savons bien et
vous avez raison vous mesdames et
messieurs de l'opposition collègues de
la nuupse surtout nous n'avons pas la
majorité absolue mais nous nous sommes
cependant avec vous Madame la première
ministre et les membres de votre
gouvernement les seuls à avoir la
capacité d'agir pour le pays avec
conscience et c'est ce que nous faisons
pour mieux gérer le quotidien essayer de
mieux prévoir le
lendemain c'est ce que fait votre
gouvernement madame la Première ministre
parce que nul ici n'est capable de
proposer une majorité alternative à la
nôtre ce qui nous intéresse pour notre
part et de nous occuper de la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens avec en
ligne de mire toujours la recherche de
l'intérêt général et de l'avenir plutôt
que promettre de satisfaire à la somme
des intérêts particuliers nous croyons
au fait d'impliquer les Français à nos
prises de décision pour réussir ensemble
Benjamin Franklin dit en 5 mois je me
souviens implique-moi j'apprends ce sera
là le sens de mon propos pour que celles
et ceux qui nous nous regardent nombreux
ce soir évidemment comprennent la
situation qui nous rassemble ce soir et
se fassent leur propres opinion pour
leur implication à l'heure où le monde
est très agité et semble avoir perdu
toute boussole à l'heure où les espoires
de paix en Ukraine au Proche Orient sont
bien mince à l'heure où l'urgence
environnementale est une évidence pour
beaucoup d'entre nous mais sans emporter
la réelle adhision de tous les pays de
notre planète à l'heure aussi où nos
concitoyens payent les conséquences des
déséquilibres internationaux et cherche
à vivre dans un monde plus serein mais
avant tout plus serein dans leur
quotidien que ce soit dans leur foyer
dans leur commune dans leur entreprise
et dans leur vie à cette heure-là les
élus que nous sommes sont là pour
transcrire leurs inquiétudes comprendre
les mots et proposer des remèdes et nous
ne sommes pas là pour alimenter ses
peurs ou importer les conflits à travers
nos mots ainsi ce que nous proposons au
français à court moyen et long terme
passe par la santé d'abord en tentant de
bl de réparer progressivement et
sincèrement les lincunes immenses qu'ont
laissé les majorités précédentes abandon
de nos territoires notamment dans la
ruralité numérus closus profession
médical et paramédical laissé à
l'abandon surtout pour les salaires
absence de vue à long terme pour nos
aînés alors même que depuis des
décennies nous savons qu'il faudra faire
face à la
dépendance cela passe par l'éducation
aussi en mettant des moyens
exceptionnels depuis près de 6 ans
maintenant pour permettre à chaque
enfant d'apprendre mieux dans de
meilleures conditions de lutter vraiment
aussi contre ce fléo qui est le
harcèlement en prenant en compte enfin
les attentes des professeurs pour la
réévaluation de leur salaire parmi les
plus bas d'Europe cela passe par le
travail ensuite celui qui émancipe celui
qui rend fier de pouvoir nourrir sa
famille et de s'occuper d'elle dignement
celui qui offre un toit péren celui qui
donne une existence dans la société
celui qui donne un statut social et
celui qui permet la reconnaissance
d'être acteur pour vivre sa vie le taux
de chômage n'a pas été aussi bas depuis
40 ans le taux d'emploi quelqu soit
l'tranche d'âge n'a jamais été aussi
haut cela passe par le développement de
notre économie la réindustrialisation de
nos territoires est une préoccupation
majeure depuis 2017 un maximum de moyens
ont été mis humains financiers fiscaux
technologiques pour que cela fonctionne
sur le long terme il en est ainsi de la
politique fiscale qui permet à notre
pays d'être en ce moment l'un des plus
attractifs de notre politique sociale
aussi avec des lois de 2017 qui ont
permis de développer les nouvelles
embauches ou encore le développement de
l'apprentissage véritable message
d'espoir pour une grande majorité de nos
jeunes bah écoute le développement est
aussi une question de vie pour nos
territoires faire en sorte que ce ne
soit pas les seules métropoles qui
bénéficient des richesses mais chaque
département de France y compris les
territoires
ultramarins les les politiques mises en
place avec les opérations action cœur de
ville ou petite ville demain permettent
de rendre aussi de l'attractivité à ces
territoires à valoriser ceux qui y
habitent nous fais faisons cela au prix
d'efforts financiers conséquents que les
précédentes majorité avaiit renoncé à
faire cela passe enfin par le réarmement
régalien juridiques et citoyens chacun
d'entre vous connaît les risques
auxquels nous faisons face sur le
territoire national comme à l'étranger
trop longtemps les majorités précédentes
ont sacrifié ces sujets soit pour des
raisons budgétaires soit pour des
raisons idéologiques laissant croître
l'insécurité et
l'adversité depuis 2017 nous avons
inversé la tendance nous voulons
protéger mieux no citoyens en renforçant
nos armées nos forces de police et notre
justice oui mesdames et messieurs de
l'opposition c'est bien tout cela qu'il
y a dans ce PLF c'est pourquoi nous le
soutenons nous soutenons l'accélération
de la transition écologique en première
partie nous continuons à verdir notre
fiscalité tout en accompagnant les
secteurs dont nos agriculteurs qui
seront touchés par la sortie des
dépenses fiscales brunes en seconde
partie nous augmentons de 10 milliards
d'euros les des enveloppes consacrées à
la planification écologique avec un très
fort ciblage pour l'accompagnement de
nos collectivités territoriales dans
leur
verdissement nos maires et présidents
d'Interco sont en première ligne face au
changement climatique leur action
admirable lors des catastrophes
climatiques nous le rappelle trop
souvent parce que ce budget nous voulons
les aider à préparer l'adaptation de
leurs outils dans cet objectif le fond
vert est pérénisé et même augmenté de
2,5 milliards d'euros nous finançons les
politiques prioritaires la jeunesse
d'abord par la revalorisation des
enseignants avec le Pact enseignant
l'augmentation du montant et du nombre
de bénéficiaires des bourses étudiantes
ou encore la montée en puissance du
service national Universal programme qui
vous le savez me tient particulièrement
à
cœur ce
budget ce budget va transformer en acte
les différentes lois de programmation
que nous avons voté notamment pour le
réarmement régalien 500 millions d'euros
supplémentaires nous permettent d'
d'enfin d'atteindre pour la première
fois 10 milliards d'euros sur la mission
justice avec un objectif de 10000
recrutements supplémentaires d'ici à
2027 nous allons enfin mettre fin selon
les mots du ministre de la Justice à la
clochardisation de la justice la mission
sécurité augmente elle aussi largement
notamment pour faire face au défis des
Jeux Olympiques 2024 dans un contexte
d'augmentation de la menace terroriste
enfin nous continuons à augmenter
fortement le budget de nos armées avec
un premier palier de 2,3 milliards
d'euros la hausse des crédits de la
mission défense doit nous permettre à
terme de faire face aux nouvelles
menaces que nous connaissons en Europe
au Proche Orient ou en
Indo-Pacifique c'est aussi un budget en
conjonction avec le PLFSS qui s'attaque
à une très forte attente de nos
concitoyens de droite de gauche et
peut-être et surtout du centre la lutte
contre la fraude contre toutes les
fraudes car la fraude qu'elle soit
fiscale ou sociale mine chaque jour un
peu plus notre confiance collective dans
notre contrat social le gouvernement a
présenté à l'été son plan fraude et ces
deux texte permett d'en faire la
traduction législative avec un meilleur
encadrement des prix du transfert la
création d'un délis spécifique pour la
création de montage frauduleux ou encore
dans le PLFSS une meilleure lutte contre
la fraude de certains professionnels de
santé ind délicat mais nous nous
n'oublions pas non plus que la
contrefaçon représente une fraude
valorisée à 10 milliards d'euros de
perte par pour l'État sans compter ses
coûts indirects sur la santé publique
l'environnement l'emploi et le
financement du crime organisé la fraude
doit être unanimement combattu tout
comme doit être communiqué avec
pédagogie les chiffres exactes de ce
qu'ell représente pour éviter de tomber
dans le sentiment de fraude constante
qui crée confusion amalgame et mine nos
compatriotes avec un fort sentiment
d'injustice ce budget a aussi été
enrichi par les débutés démocrat en
première partie un peu en seconde partie
un peu plus peut-être je n'en ferai pas
une litanie mais permettez-moi d'en
saluer quelques réalisations d'abord
Erwan Baladan nous avons souhaiter
flécher 30 million d'euros
supplémentaires sur un fléo que nous
rencontrons tous dans nos
circonscriptions et qui trop souvent en
deuil des familles entières le
harcèlement scolaire avec perine Goulet
qui a souhaité améliorer la prise en
charge juridictionnelle des mineurs en
lien avec la loi de programmation de la
justice avec Marina Ferrari nous avons
présenté un amendement pour augmenter le
budget pour la restructuration des
locaux commerciant et d'artisanat dans
les zones fragiles nos commerçants nos
artisans sont nos patrimoines et nous
les aidons aujourd'hui mené par France
gums notre groupe a aussi eu une
attention particulière pour les outres
mèes avec l'élargissement d'Action
Logement à Saint-Pierre et miclon et à
Saint-Martin une meilleure prise en
charge des cancers un abandement du FEI
ou avec un engagement en particulier de
ma part sur la sécurité
routière tous nos souhaits n'ont
néanmoins malheureusement pas été
entendus et nous continuerons à faire
des propositions dans les prochains mois
en matière fiscale et budgétaire nous
avons de la suite dans nos idées et de
la détermination à défendre des idées
qui nous semblent justes et essentielles
pour l'intérêt général et notre
pays pour conclure ce budget trace donc
c'est pour que vous suivez chers
collègues ce budget trace donc ainsi des
lignes de prochain des prochains mois
nous le saluons mais il ne suffira pas
nous devons continuer à travailler avec
votre gouvernement madame la Première
ministre dans les prochaines semaines et
dans les prochains mois en premier lieu
en luttant mieux contre l'immigration
illégale tout en intégrant mieux les
quelques milliers qui sont aujourd'hui
ici et qui en travaillant apportent déjà
à notre société on est bien lo là du
danger de la régularisation massive tant
qu' porté par C
s'il y a quelque chose de massif dans
cette loi c'est bien les plus de 20
articles dans ce projet de loi qui
veillent à rétablir plus de contrôle
plus de sanctions vis-à-vis de celles et
ceux qui ne respectent pas notre
pays nous devons ensuite aussi avancer
sur notre approvisionnement énergétique
et les travaux que vous avez menés à
l'échelle européenne vont dans le bon
sens il y a urgence maintenant
rapidement à les décliner nationalement
enfin un grand projet de loi logement
nous semble indispensable c'est l'un des
mots de notre société à l'origine de
tous les autres mots que nous cherchons
à soigner au quotidien avoir un grand
projet de loi logement ambitieux
efficace à court et moyen terme réaliste
fonctionnel solidaire fraternel et
visionnaire et la clé de voûte à
l'harmonie de notre société et vous
savez madame la Première ministre que
nous serons à vos côtés sur ce sujet
avec des propositions innovantes et
sérieuse nous avons encore beaucoup de
travail parce que ce PLF est l'un des
vecteurs essentiels pour continue à
faire vivre mieux nos concitoyens parce
que le groupe démocrate continue à
vouloir s'impliquer à vos côtés et pour
notre nation vous l'aurez compris nous
ne voterons pas laabotion de censure je
vous
remercie merci Monsieur
Blanchet la parole est à Monsieur Michel
Boulou pour le groupe socialiste et
[Applaudissements]
apparenté
bonsoir
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues et de
16 cela va vous surprendre madame la
Première ministre mais j'aimerais
commencer par compatir amicalement à
votre
situation 6 493 cette année 16 en tout
un 17e qui se prépare pour lundi vous
devez vous lasser
mais surtout si je veux compatir
amicalement à à ce sort c'est que ces
493 sont un souci pour vous d'ici à Noël
vous en serez à 23 il vous en faudra au
minimum 10 de plus pour les budgets de
l'année prochaine ce qui vous en amènera
à 33 soit au-dessus du chiffre
symbolique des 28 de Michel Rocard
or je doute que le Président de la
République voudra battre ce record
autrement dit la méthode que vous que
vous avez choisi sur ces budgets est en
train de sceller lentement mais sûrement
votre propre sort vous allez nous dire
la main sur le cœur que vous n'avez pas
le choix personne ne veut vot TL vos
budgets et cetera et
cetera objection votre honneur
oui quand personne n'est satisfait de
vos budgets personne ne veut les voter
c'est assez naturel c'est simple c'est
basique mais je crois qu'on a déjà vu
des situations où après quelques efforts
vos budgets pouvaient paraître tolérable
à certains dans cet hémicycle alors j'en
conviens ça ne date pas d'hier puisque
la dernière fois en fait c'était
littéralement hier en fait hier ou de
nombreuses oppositions se sont abstenus
sur le budget de fin de gestion 2023
parce que vous avez consenti à discuter
avec elle et chercher un accord et à
faire des gestes 150 € pour les 600000
par an seul 200 million d'euros pour
l'aide
alimentaire 2 million d'euros dans la
lutte contre les algues Sargasses
envahissantes un peu plus d'argent pour
l'hébergement d'urgence ce n'est pas la
panacée certes mais c'est déjà ça
imaginez cela transposez-le à un budget
annuel
imaginez mais sur le budget de l'année
prochaine vous n'avez même pas essayer
de discuter que ce soit avec la gauche
ou avec la droite et pour le coup vous
pouvez même pas dire que vous que vous
ne savez pas ce qu'il faut faire c'est
inédit jamais autant de groupes de cet
hémicycle n'avait présenté des
contrebudgets cette année nous
socialistes nous avons fait un
contrebudget un contrebudget à
l'équilibre au passage avec choix
politiques fort contre la vie cherre et
pour la transition écologique lisez-le
nos collègues insoumis ont aussi fait le
leur
lisez-le nos collègues républicains en
ont fait un également
lisez-le bon personne n'attend du
rassemblement national qu'il fasse
preuve de sérieux en proposant un projet
cohérent mais
passons mais mais vous aviez l'embarras
du
choix vous avez l'arme nucléaire donc
vous êtez vous ne vous embêtez pas vous
l'utilisez c'est tellement plus simple
que de débattre cette arme le 493 sera
votre perte c'est dommage je vous le dis
en toute
amitié sur le fond sans faire un cours
d'histoire complet vous connaissez
l'histoire des États Généraux de 1789
réunis en pleine crise financière et
budgétaire et vous savez sans doute
comme moi que la raison d'être
historique du Parlement c'est de voter
l'IMP et son
usage avec votre méthode pour la deè
année nous n'avons pas pu discuter des
impôts avec un 493 immédiat nous n'avons
pas pu discuter sérieusement des
dépenses puisque sur les 47 missions et
comptes spéciaux nous avons pu commencer
les discussions de ne missions et encore
nous n'ons même pas pu aller au vote sur
la
plupart c'est la deè année que c'est le
cas et si vous ne changez pas de manière
de faire nous allons passer 5 ans sans
vote quelle démocratie moderne passe 5
ans sans pouvoir voter sans même pouvoir
discuter de ses impôts et de son
budget dans un pays où la critique de la
verticalité du pouvoir est récurrente
depuis 60 ans nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyennes reçoivent chaque semaine
sur leur téléphone des alerte de leur
journaux Elisabeth born déclenche un
nouveau
493 beaucoup ne se demandent même plus
pourquoi et ont intégré que de toute
façon la vie du peuple ou de ses
représentants ce n'est pas votre affaire
ce n'est pas celle du
président alors comment ne pas
comprendre que nos concitoyens se disent
que leur parole n'a aucun
impact qu'il qu'il se désintéresse de la
politique ou qu'il se déclare même
indifférent à l'arrivée de forces encore
plus
autoritaire 34 % en 2017 41,5 % en 2022
combien en 2027 combien fera l'extrême
droite après 10 ans à exercer le pouvoir
comme vous le
faites plus égoïstement ces 493
répétitions sont désespérants pour nous
aussi parlementaires notre travail est
réduit à néant pour ce budget ce sont
des centaines d'organismes qui ont été
auditionnés afin de faire remonter leurs
attentes et leurs problématique pour
rien pour ma part en tant que
corapporteur spécial du budget de la
mission consacré à la recherche avec mon
collègue Jean-Marc Tellier j'ai entendu
près d'une vingtaine d'organismes que ce
soit le CNRS l'Agence nationale de la
recherche l'Institut pol000 Victor pour
la recherche polaire ou encore
l'Institut national du cancer ou les
syndicats de chercheurs tout ce travail
d'écoute de concertation et
d'intelligence
collective pour que dans la solitude
d'un bureau gris de Bery soit décidé de
rejeter des amendements pourtant voter
en commission et même dans
l'hémicycle ou encore pire sortir du
chapeau des mesures nouvelles on se
demande à quoi bon à quoi on sert les
Français aussi et ils n'ont pas
totalement
tort vous allez nous dire que vous avez
retenu 550 amendements en tout d'accord
mais combien la majorité combien des
oppositions et surtout il n'en reste pas
moins que ces amendements n'ont pas été
choisis par un vote mais par un
fonctionnaire un conseiller ministériel
ou par des négociations de dessous de
table sans vote
l'antidémocratie
quand ils ont entendu parler de
l'amendement
FIFA combien de nos concitoyenes et
concitoyens se sont dit que c'était
encore une fois la République des
coquins et des copains mesurez-vous le
mal que ce genre d'amendement lobby fait
à votre action et le mal qu'il fait à la
crédibilité de tous les politiques de ce
pays sur le texte lui-même et bien je
n'ai même pas envie de rentrer dans son
côté contreproductif parfois indécent
souvent inefficace sur ces insuffisances
que ce soit pour la bifurcation
écologique l'école la justice fiscale
l'outrem le social on l'a déjà fait on n
pas arrêté de le faire mais là ce soir
je NIS plus le cœur madame la Première
ministre car vous n'écoutez pas pét de
vos certitudes les Françaises et les
Français voient votre cynisme dans la
gestion des affaires il voient la
brutalité de votre manière de gouverner
il voi nos institutions se déliter et
perdre de leur sens et il voit que cela
vous laisse de marbre ces motions de
censure à répétition confinent peut-être
à l'absurde mais l'exercice a une forme
de nécessité car après tout c'est
quelque part le dernier endroit
d'expression qu'il nous reste c'est
malheureux je vous
remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à madame Lise
manier pour le groupe horizon et
apparenté
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues je
dois vous dire que j'ai hésité avant
d'écrire mon intervention de ce soir
voilà un an que les motions de censure
se suivent et se ressemblent les
interventions pour les soutenir et les
repousser aussi je dois dire que c'est
légèrement fastidieux pour nous pour
vous membres du gouvernement et sans
doute encore plus pour les courageux qui
nous écoutent chacun se range
confortablement dans son rôle les uns
dénonce une démocratie brutalisée tandis
que les autres témoignent de la
nécessité de voir adopter tel ou tel
texte et ce soir particulièrement le
projet de loi de finances alors j'aurais
pu axer mon intervention sur deux ou
trois idées qui me sembleent pourtant
assez simple mais comme il paraît que la
pédagogie et l'art de la de la
répétition redisons-le
d'abord il est essentiel de doter notre
état d'un budget en temps et en heure
ensuite le recours à l'article 49 alinéa
3 est inéluctable pour faire adopter le
projet de loi de finance dans la
configuration de notre assemblée qui ne
dispose pas d'une majorité absolue et où
l'usage veut que le vote du budget
détermine l'appartenance à la
majorité chacun étant donc dans son rôle
une grande théatralisation des réactions
que très peu d'intérêt et si ce budget
n'est sûrement pas parfait il est
sérieux et crédible et surtout le
gouvernement a a mener un travail
minutieux pour reprendre des amendements
de tous les groupes parlementaires qui
viennent enrichir le texte ce n'était en
rien une obligation le texte final
aurait pu être arrêté sans il faut donc
le mettre à votre crédit madame la
Première ministre et le groupe Horizon
est apparenté vous en est
reconnaissant et puis une fois ces Obs
liminire fa qui ne bouscule pas
l'histoire de la pensée j'en conviens je
pourrais passer à l'attaque des
oppositions dire qu'elles n'ont pas de
majorité alternative que leurs
contrebudgets sont utopiques et qu'elles
sont confortablement installées dans une
position de commentateur et de critiqu
qui ne fait que très peu avancer le
débat finalement mais je crois
profondément madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers
collègues que le moment que traverse
notre pays est beaucoup trop grave pour
tous ce là les Français qui expriment
régulièrement leur décrochage avec une
classe politique à laquelle ils
reprochent 1000 mots quel qu'ell soit
sont là d'entendre les vocifération et
anathème dont certains sont devenus
champions notre pays vit une crise
existentielle profonde l'importation de
conflit extérieurs sur notre sol n'est
plus une crainte infondée la résurgence
au grand jour de l'antisémitisme et du
racisme au sein de notre peuple doit
nous alerter puissant
des lignes rouges ont été franchies ces
dernières semaines par l'extrême gauche
qui fait le choix clair et assumé de
jouer délibérément le jeu du chaos
permanent pour des gains électoraux
hypothétiques nous ne pouvons l' tolérer
il nous faut y opposer un discours fort
notre rôle notre priorité doitêre
doivent être totalement axé sur la
reconstruction de notre nation en cela
ici mes chersègues de la franceoumise pl
et avir un débat d'idé sin leadictoire
esté
et le respect de l'autre ser
imptif
[Musique]
écter deousé d'assurer un avenir
partagé j'ai eu l'honneur de représenter
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale ce matin à colombelle les deux
église pour la cérémonie d'hommage au
général de Gaulle faut-il rappeler ce
que ce grand homme a fait et donné pour
que nous en soyons aujourd'hui ces bien
heureux héritiers peut-on simplement
essayer de respecter l'engagement de nos
grands aînés l'ensemble des combats
qu'ils ont menés pour nous ils ont
défendu corps et âmes nos valeurs ils
ont réconcilié le peuple ils ont protégé
notre promesse républicaine il n'est pas
possible de continuer à abîmer la France
comme certain comme certains
pseudoesonsables politiques le font
aujourd'hui il nous faut impérativement
nous mobiliser collectivement pour
mettre la base politique de côté pour le
bien de notre nation madame la Première
ministre vous avez toute notre confiance
nous serons là à vos côtés pour lutter
avec force contre toute forme de rejet
de l'autre et défendre les valeurs qui
sont les ntres la liber
l'égalité et la fraternité je vous
remercie merci Madame anier s'il vous
plaît chers
collègues j'ai demandé de bien vouloir
vous
[Musique]
écouter il y a pas eu d'insulte dans ce
cas dit Madame manier s'il vous plaît
non non non écoutez je l'ai
attentivement écoute s'il vous plaît bon
s'il vous plaît monsieur non mais
attendez attendez à ce jeu à ce jeul on
s'en sort pas non mais attendez ce sont
des expressions d'opinion comme Monsieur
léomand tout à l'heure qui exprimé une
opinion et Madame manier a écouté très
attentivement et on ne peut pas réagir
s'il vous plaît à chaque phrase la
parole est donc à Monsieur Benjamin Luca
pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
écologiste
si si merci madame la Présidente si si
le gouvernement peut éviter de faire des
des commentaires desésobligeants quand
on monte à la tribune c'est quand même
agréable je voudrais dire madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
mesames et messieurs les ministres chers
collègues que pour un jeune
parlementaire d'opposition avoir le
privilège d'un quasi tête à-tête avec la
chef du gouvernement est une occasion
normalement rare mais qui grâce à
l'usage répété des 493 c'est bien leur
seule vertu de mon point de vue me
permet une fois de plus même la première
ministre de quasiment pouvoir obtenir un
rendez-vous en direct avec vous et de
vous dire quelques mots cont tenu de
l'affluence dans l'hémicycle ce soir
alors vous me permettrez madame la
Première ministre puisque la collègue
précédente manier nous invitait à ne pas
reproduire les mêmes interventions que
nous faisons à chaque fois lors de
chaque motion de censure qui suit chaque
493 d'essayer de vous parler avec cœur
de ce que le parlementaire que je suis
aussi légitime que les autres ressent en
cet instant et et à chaque fois que
frappe votre 493 l'an dernier nous
pouvions débattre mais pas voter cette
année nous ne pouvons même plus débattre
vous intervenez vous arrivez dans cet
hémicycle sans aucune forme de cohérence
avec l'ordre du jour qui est le nôre
parfois en plein milieu d'une d'une
mission en l'occurrence il y a quelques
jours sur les les anciens combattants et
la mémoire vous montez à la tribune vous
lisez alors je suis un écologiste je
suis forcément pour le recyclage mais
quand même vous lisez le même discours
avec les mêmes arguments les mêmes mots
et vous vous décidez des 493 selon votre
bon vouloir oserais-je dire même selon
votre bon plaisir tant on sent une forme
de jouissance dans la majorité
présidentielle à l'idée d'humilier le
Parlement mais comme l'a dit mon
collègue léoment tout à l'heure madame
la Première ministre nous ne sommes pas
ici au théâtre nous sommes ici dans le
temple de la démocratie un temple de la
démocratie que vous salissez à travers
les débats que vous empêchez et je parle
bien des débats madame la première prre
ministre à travers les débats que vous
empêchez il y en a un qui me tenait
particulièrement à cœur sur lequel je
n'ai pas pu présenter le moindre
amendement ni même tenter de convaincre
mes collègues qui est la promesse que
nous faisons à nos électrices à nos
électeurs quand nous nous présentons à
leur suffrage lors des élections
législatives c'est un engagement que
nous partageons avec mes collègues
vanagier et Simonet qui fait écho au
drame vécu par la famille du jeune
Hotman
âgé de 7 ans qui est décédé en 2015 à
cause d'un asenseur défectueux à
mant-elajolie dans le quartier du
valfouret dont j'ai l'honneur d'être le
parlementaire madame la Première
ministre j'avais déposé des amendement
dans le cadre de ce projet de loi de
finances pour faire des propositions
concrètes constructives qui permettent
concrètement de répondre à cette
situation qui concerne la sécurité dans
les ascenseurs de nos quartiers
populaires 637000 ascenseurs dans notre
pays c'est le premier transport en
commun du quotidien je le déposer ces
amendements parce que j'ai fait cette
promesse à la mère du jeune Hotman et
que chaque 10 octobre 2015 à l'évocation
de l'anniversaire de son décès je me
sens le devoir sacré républicain de
porter ce combat ici c'est une question
importante tant tant de nos compatriotes
sont par faute d'entretien de ces
ascenseurs confinés à leur domicile et
les témoignages sont nombreux je sais
qu'ils sont connus et compris sur tous
les
bancs madame la Première ministre les
ascenseurs dans notre pays sont donc je
vous l'ai dit 637000 ils tombent en moy
VI en panne trois fois par an dans le
parc social c'est 9 à 10 fois par an et
les délais de réparation sont plus gros
sont plus grands voilà quelque chose
notamment qui aurait dû figurer dans vos
propositions et vos engagements
concernant les quartiers populaires
voilà ce dont j'aurais aimé pouvoir
parler ce sur quoi nous aurions aimé
avec mes collègues vanagier et Simonet
convaincre des collègues de voter le
plan d'urgence le fond d'urgence que
nous proposions voilà concrètement un
débat qui aurait fait honneur à ce
Parlement honneur au gouvernement pour
changer concrètement la vie de nos
concitoyens et pour répondre loin des
agents anction loin des discours
martiaux loi des gadgets tels que le SNU
aux vraies aspirations de nos quartiers
populaires madame la Première ministre
nos quartiers populaires méritent mieux
que les injonctions méritent mieux que
le paternalisme mérit mieux que des
appels sans lendemain à respecter la loi
quand vous ne donnez même plus de sens à
ceux qui font la loi à l'endroit où on
fait la loi à l'Assemblée nationale
comment exiger de nos concitoyens que la
loi républicaine soit respectée quand il
voit comment le Parlement qui est censé
faire la loi et lui-même bafoué en
permanence comment sans cesse vous le
faites stigmatiser les parents quand
vous faites preuve à l'égard des
parlementaires de beaucoup moins de
dignité que des centaines de milliers de
familles qui dans notre pays chaque jour
apprennent à leurs enfants le respect
des règles républicaines le respect du
savoir-vvre quand vous-même ne respectez
même pas le savoir-vre à l'égard des
parlementaires jamais jamais on a vu un
gouvernement rigoler interpeller des
collègues pendant qu'il s'expriment à ce
point ne même pas respecter les 10
pauvres minutes de temps de parole que
nous avons pour vous exprimer un message
vous m'avez interpellé trois fois depuis
le début de mon intervention le ministre
de la Justice qui n'est pas là
aujourd'hui pour cause de procès a fait
un bras d'honneur à un de nos collègues
est-ce une façon d'enseigner le respect
des règles
[Musique]
républicaines je vous le dis madame la
Première ministre pour que notre devise
républicaine liberté égalité fraternité
est un sens et mon collègue léomand l'a
très bien dit tout à l'heure il faut
qu'elle s'incarne dans la vie
quotidienne de chacune et de chacun
comment pouvons-nous ensemble créer du
commun construire des diagnostics
partager parfois des divergences et
exposer des solutions sur tous les
problèmes que rencontrent nos
compatriotes si nous ne pouvons même pas
même pas discuter du projet de loi de
finances si nous ne pouvons même pas
débattre sereinement ici argument contre
argument du du projet de loi de
financeces vous invoquez Michel Rocard
en permanence et les 493 mais madame la
Première ministre il y a une différence
fondamentale entre un 493 qui intervient
une fois qu'on a fait le constat qu'on
avait pas réussi à convaincre et l'aveu
d'échec est noble en politique il faut
savoir dire que l'on a échoué et le 493
qui intervient pendant la discussion
parfois même au lendemain une seconde
même après les discussions générales et
qui vient clore tout débat toute
possibilité pour les représentants du
peuple que nous sommes autant que nos
collègues de la majorité a exprimer Mad
madame la Présidente le ministre des
Relations avec le par nentendons jamais
jamais qui a ici la même utilité que
penéope Fillon quand elle travaillait
pour François Fillon VI m'interp pour la
5è fois consécutive madame la Présidente
je demande que vous rappiez alors le
ministre des Relations avec le Parlement
qu'il me laisse terminer mon prop trs
bien alors je demande un peu de calme et
je demande à
jeraable s'il vous plats monie peutêtre
peut-être souhaitez-vous remplacer
monsieur Dupont
Moretti à Gou j'ai dro d'interper le
gouvernement pour ça non mais attende
attendez s'il vous plaît il vous restes
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît on va
retrouver un peu de calme monsieur Lucas
je vous propose de poursuivre votre
intervention jusqu'au bout sur le sujet
et je demande à chacun de vouloir
écouter monsieur Lucas avec
attentionerci madame la Présidente et je
tiens je tiens à le dire
calmement nous sommes dans un moment
dans lequel notre démocratie est
affaiblie a-je besoin de vous rappeler
que partout en Europe l'extrême droite
progresse AJE besoin de vous rappeler
que dans notre pays vous avez été élu
réélu uniquement parce que des hommes et
des femmes de bonne volonté par million
ont voulu faire barrage à l'extrême
droite et éviter le pire dans notre pays
nous sommes dans un moment de tension
extrême nombre de nos concitoyens ne
croient plus dans la démocratie que nous
représentons nous avons l'impérieux
devoir commun de permettre que s'exprime
dans cette assemblée les débats qui
traversent la société et votre devoir
comme gouvernement issu d'une majorité
d'autant plus d'une majorité minoritaire
parce que tels l'ont voulu les Français
qui ont refusé de vous accorder les
pleins pouvoirs vous devez tenir compte
de cette réalité permettre que s'exprime
ici le débat démocratique madame la
Première ministre je vous le dis parce
que je veux pouvoir comme tous mes
collègues j'en suis sûr honorer mon
mandat pouvoir porter ici la parole de
la famille du jeune Hotman qui demande
que nous agissions pour que les
ascenseurs de nos quartiers populaires
soient sûrs pour qu'on ne meurt plus
étouffé par sa trottinette parce qu'un
ascenseur est défectueux qui n'a pas été
réparé et il n'y a madame la Première
ministre pas de quoi rire quand j'ai
évoque ces drames vraiment pas de quoi
rire je vous l'assure il n'y a pas de
quoi quoi rire quand j'évoque ces drames
je vous demande du respect du respect
pour le cas que j'évoque pour la
situation que j'évoque et pour le
parlementaire que je suis pour les
parlementaires que nous sommes vous avez
vous-même été élu député madame la
Première ministre en juin 2022 vous
reviendrez un jour peut-être demain si
nous votons la censure ce soir une
parlementaire je souhaite et j'espère
que vous serez davantage respecté comme
parlementaire de la majorité aujourd'hui
de l'opposition demain que vous ne
respecter les parlementaires aujourd'hui
il se joue là bien plus qu'un budget
bien plus qu'un débat entre majorité et
opposition il se joue notre capacité
commune à préserver la démocratie et à
dire à nos concitoyens que la démocratie
représentative que la démocratie
parlementaire est encore capable de
porter ici les grandes questions qui
traversent la société parce que nos
compatriotes attendent de nous par-dà
nos choix divergents que nous discutions
tant des façons de répondre à leurs
urgences du quotidien que de relever les
grands défis de l'avenir et ils sont
nombreux à l'heure du péril climatique à
l'heure de la montée du nationalisme de
l'antisémitisme du de l'islamophobie de
la haine de toutes les forme
d'intolérance il nous faut être à la
hauteur madame la Première ministre vous
êtes le gouvernement de la République
vous devez garantir qu'ici on puisse
débattre qu'ici on puisse voter qu'ici
on puisse faire la loi que nous ayons à
le demander que nous ayons à monter à
cette tribune pour la 16e fois et demain
pour la 17e fois pour la 18e fois pour
la 19e fois pour la 20 que saisje encore
pour vous en
supplier relève d'un drame mais d'un
drame qui ne concerne pas que vous parce
que vous ne tomberez pas seul vous ferez
tomber avec vous la République et la
démocratie parlementaire et cela est
[Applaudissements]
dramatique merci Monsieur
ls la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Marc
Tellier pour le groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et
[Applaudissements]
républicaine
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre chers
collègues vous comprendrez qu'avant de
commencer mon propos je voudrais avoir
une pensée pour les habitants de mon
département du Pas decalis qui doivent
faire face à ces inondations inédite
depuis plusieurs
[Applaudissements]
jours madame la Première ministre notre
démocratie s'évanouit peu à peu le
gouvernement use du 493 avec une telle
légèreté qu'il semble presque faire fi
de nos principes démocratiques alors que
nulle formation politique ici ne veut
prétendre à une majorité absolue dans
cette assemblée vous devriez d'autant
plus vous orienter vers la nécessité de
la
concertation votre tâche ne devrait donc
pas consister à rassembler des voix au
gré des vents et des projets ni même à
exercer un chantage inédit dans cette
assemblée la richesse des débats en
commission les voix transpartisanes
s'unissant sur un certain nombre
d'amendements se voi méprisé ignoré
écarté d'un revers de main
autoritaire votre discours embrouillé de
justification tortueusees ne serait
dissimulé la vérité le 493 est
aujourd'hui dévoyé en une arme
antidémocratique son utilisation
systématique n d'gal dans aucune
démocratie moderne c'est une facilité un
simulatre de débat et c'est même avec
les dialogues de bercille qui n'était en
vérité que le prélude d'une fin déjà
écrite vous prenez le débat mais nos
voix sont étouffé par vos
pratiques en passant outre nos
prérogatives vous mettez en péril le bon
fonctionnement de nos institution et
aggraver la défiance des citoyens
d'ailleurs votre intention d'utiliser
cet article exprimz bien avant la
présentation du projet de loi témoigne
d'une marque criante de considération
non seulement envers les parlementaires
mais aussi envers les concitoyens cette
parodie n'est pas la de notre
pays vous avez dit madame la Première
ministre que la discussion budgétaire se
déroulait à un rythme particulièrement
lent quelle belle affaire n'est-il pas
essentiel d'accorder à notre démocratie
toutes les ressources et tout le temps
nécessaire sans rien lui retenir dans
son droit tout entier à s'exprimer sur
un sujet
tel d'une telle importance que le budget
surtout sur un budget qui justement
porté par la froideur de son austérité
avait largement besoin d'être humanisé
car quit de l'humain dans cette affaire
où se terrent les réelles mesures pour
le pouvoir d'achat la santé l'éducation
l'emploi sans vote et sans débat vous
pariez toujours sur une croissance à 1,4
% en 2024 des prévisions très optimistes
et un haut rendement de la TVA en
réalité vous faites peser tout le poids
sur nos classes populaires qui paiont
toujours plus mais qui auront
assez accès à toujours moins vous allez
abaisser des dépenses publiques de 17
milliards d'euros l'an prochain contre
16 initialement vous affirmez vouloir la
chasse aux mauvaises dépens mais en
réalité c'est la casse des services
publics qui s'intensifie en réalité vous
nous faites qu'une seule promesse encore
plus
d'austérité ce projet de loi de
financeces qui prévoit des dépenses
fiscales de près de 80 milliards d'euros
fait la part belle aux aides aux
entreprises à une minorité d'acteurs
économiques parmi les dépenses fiscales
les crédits d'impôt le crédit d'impôt
recherche sur lequel nous avons donc pas
pu débattre en séance représente une
dépense significative dont l'efficacité
n'est clairement pas démontrée ce sont
principalement les grandes entreprises
qui bénéficient du CIR et non pas nos
petites et moyennes entreprises qui
mériteraient au contraire bien plus de
soutien
etide de notre population nos classe
populaire et moyenne qui aujourd'hui
font face à la fin et sont contraintes
de faire d'énormes sacrifices pour
boucler les fins de mois les Français ne
veulent pas le B ils à vivre
correctement de leur travail sans avoir
besoin de chque alimentaire ou de panier
anti-inflation la première préoccupation
des Français est claire le pouvoir
d'achat mais votre budget que ce soit
dans sa partie recette ou dépens et lui
clairement éloigné de cette réalité dans
un contexte où l'inflation alimentaire
atteint un taux alarmant de 20 % la
hausse des prix de toutes part exerce
une pression considérable sur les
ménages les plus vulnérables ainsi que
sur les travailleurs pauvres oui c'est
notre paradoxe une France si riche mais
où de nombreux travailleurs peineent à
joindre les débouts et c'est d'autant
plus vrai pour nos concitoyens des
outremèes madame la Première ministre la
grande pauvreté est 5 à 15 fois plus
fréquente dans les département d'outremè
qu'en France métropolitaine comment
pouvons-nous accepter aujourd'hui à
l'horizon 2020 4 même s'il faut noter
quelques financements supplémentaires
c'est loin d'être un rattrapage
suffisant du retard du développement que
subissent les territoires ultramarins
depuis très longtemps ils font face à
des carences profondes qui affectent la
vie quotidienne de leur habitants
rappelons-nous l'état précaire du
logement l'ampleur de l'habitat Adine
les infrastructures les routes les
obstacles à l'acès à l'accès à l'eau
potable
ces problèmes ne sont pas seulement des
statistiques ce sont des réalités vécues
qui affectent des centaines de milliers
de nos concitoyens la crise du logement
écriante des milliers de logements
sociaux en attente dans un contexte où
l'offre est dramatiquement insuffisante
et l'eau cette ressource fondamentale
l'UR est encore
inaccessible où sont les investissements
massifs pour garantir l'accès à l' pour
tous pensez-vous que 50 millions
suffiront à régler la crise de l'eau à
Mayotte ces budgets tout comme ceux qui
l'ont précédé ne parviennent pas à
renverser le non développement qui ronge
les territoires ultramarins il faut
aussi dire un mot sur le nucléaire comme
le dit le président de la Polynésie la
dette nucléaire est une bombe économique
et sociale ce budget qui privilégie
fortement la situation nucléaire dans
son volet défense reste beaucoup plus
discret en ce qui concerne le
dédommagement des victimes des 30 années
décès nucléaire madame la Première
ministre avec ce processus budgétaire
écourté et réduit à une simple formalité
vous nous soumettez aujourd'hui un texte
qui ne reprend pas qui ne répond pas aux
besoins et aux aspirations de nos
concitoyens les riches sont soyés
pendant que les pauvres portent le
fardeau et au-delà même du budget
aujourd'hui nous devons nous interroger
sur l'état de notre démocratie nous
devons pouvoir débattre dans cette
édifice qui est l'Assemblée nationale
témoin silencieux de l'histoire qui
incarne l'esprit de la démocratie il est
not de notre devoir de préserver son âme
de garantir que chaque tribune continue
à raisonner des débats et des
idéosémocratiques qui l'ont façonné nous
avons d'ailleurs le plaisir tous les
jours mes chers collègues d'ouvrir ses
portes aux nombreux jeunes élèves de nos
circonscriptions leur permettant de
toucher du bout des doigts l'histoire et
de les éveiller à leur
citoyenneté mais il y a une nombre
tableau une
disonance entre le lieu et son essence
l'assemblée ne doit pas devenir un musée
de la démocratie elle doit en être
l'incarnation vivante si nous laissons
cet endroit perdre de son sens ces mêmes
élèves et les générations futures qui
les suivront ne visiteront plus qu'une
coquille vide c'est dans cette esprit
pour toutes ces raisons et bien d'autres
que le groupe GDR votera évidemment pour
la motion de
censure merci Monsieur
thier la parole est à monsieur le
Président Pancher pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre M et
territoire
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre Mames messieurs les ministres
chers collègues je vais revenir dans un
instant
sur le budget le
493 sur la motion de censure qui nous
réunit ce soir mais en prélude vous
m'autoriserai à prendre un peu de recul
je veux en effet vous faire part de mon
inquiétude sur la situation de notre
pays je veux dire ce soir ma colère
quand je vois les polémiques les petits
calculs politique mesquin qui viennent
perturber l'organisation du
rassemblement organisé ce dimanche à
l'initiative de la présidente de
l'Assemblée national et du Sénat autour
d'une cause qui devrait pourtant nous
unir dimanche avec les membres du groupe
lot je manifesterai pour la République
contre
l'antisémitisme sans hésitation car
c'est notre devoir de lutter contre le
racisme et
l'antisémitisme qui vont à l'encontre de
notre belle devise républicaine liberté
égalité et fraternité la fraternité tous
frères et sœurs de notre si beau pays la
France plus largement c'est l'état de la
France qui m'alarme ces fractures de
plus en plus grandes et ces factures que
nos concitoyens n'arrivent plus à payer
la société française est profondément
divisée àan influancé par la litanie des
discours
déclinistes nous devons affronter des
menaces et des foyers d'instabilité
guerre en Ukraine conflit au Proche
Orient changement géostratégique ou
encore bouleversement climatique dont
nous voyons de plus en plus les effets
dans la situation actuelle il est plus
que Vital de chercher des compromis
politiques responsables il en va dans
cette assemblée euh avec une majorité
relative et des oppositions chacun y a
sa place et concourt au débat public
tous ici nous sommes au service de nos
compatriotes et de notre pays nous avons
eu l'occasion de vous dire notre
opposition à votre projet de budget
n'est pas dogmatique mais nourri de
notre réflexion je veux vous alerter sur
la trajectoire des finances publiques
notre déficit très élevé la remontée des
taux qui augurent d'une augmentation
insupportable de la charge de la dette
52 milliards en 2024 84 milliards en
2027 et cette dette qui rogne les marges
de manœuvre du politique ceci est
d'autant plus inquiétant que cette
situation dégradée ne résulte pas de
grands investissements pour l'avenir les
infrastructures la transition écologique
mais d'une augmentation des dépenses de
fonctionnement nous avons salué
l'augmentation des crédits pour les
forces de sécurité pour les armé pour
l'école peut-on autant dire que nos
services publics fonctionnent bien
certainement pas n devons nous
interroger sur l'efficacité de la
dépense publique sur la technocratie en
folie que je dénonce régulièrement j'en
appelle une fois plus à cette tribune un
choc de simplification qui passe
nécessairement par un grand choc de
décentralisation le sentiment qui
prédomine ce soir alors que nous sache
fons l'examen d'un texte majeur celui
qui donne un budget à notre pays c'est
la frustration et la déception nous
avons examiné certaines missions
quelques budgets de certains ministères
et les débats intéressants ont eu lieu
des amendements ont été adoptés de la
majorité ou des oppositions mais très
peu se retrouent devant ce texte final
vous avez fait le choix d'escamoter le
débat parlementaire ce qui n'est pas bon
pour la démocratie la Constitution vous
permet évidemment le recours illimité au
493 sur les textes budgétaires cela nous
le savons tous néanmoins nous le voyons
cette pratique du pouvoir a des effets
dévastateurs sur nos institutions nous
le redisons le 493 affaiblit la pratique
démocratique et affaiblit le
gouvernement qui y recourt c'est
d'ailleurs une double peine pour les
territoires ruraux et les territoires
éloigné tant la forteresse de Bery les
connaît peu ou les ignore mais je crois
aussi
que l'accumulation des motions de
censure voué à l'échec tend également à
banaliser le recours à cette procédure
d'exception ce budget je l'ai dit n'est
pas le nôtre mais fidèle à notre
positionnement d'opposition et de
proposition nous avons œuvré pour
l'améliorer notre groupe a joué le jeu
de la concertation nous avons participé
au dialogue de Bery nous avons discuté
avec le ministre en charge du budget de
l'économie et le ministre ministre
délégué au Budget nous avons aussi
répondu à votre invitation et je tiens à
vous remercier pour cette disponibilité
d'un mot je vous dirai nos craintes sur
la crise du logement la construction le
logement social sont à l'arrêt les
chiffres des rénovations ne sont pas
assez importants nous regrettons que
vous n'ayez pas gardé notre amendement
qui renforcit les appels accession car
les Français rencontrent des difficultés
inédites pour se loger
sur notre jeunesse qui nourrit des
craintes et qui attend autre chose que
le service national universel nous avons
fait des propositions pour mieux les
accompagner les augmentations notamment
des bourses vous les vous ne les avez
pas conservé sur la justice enfin et
notamment fiscal il y a un débat sur la
juste participation de tous à l'effort
collectif vous avez initié des réformes
fiscales depuis 2017 qui profiteent
davantage au plus aisé plusieurs groupes
de la majorité et des oppositions dont
le nôtre ont fait des propositions pour
rétablir davantage de justice en
direction des gfames des rachats
d'actions des opérations spéculatives en
bourse vous les avez toutes ignoré c'est
dommage elles étaient utiles pour
diminuer nos
déficits nous avons aussi entendu la
préoccupation première de nos
compatriotes le pouvoir d'achat je
dirais même plus l'inquiétude le pouvoir
de vivre les Français que je rencontre
et désormais même celles et ceux qui
travaillent dur me disent qu'ils ont
tous de plus en plus de mal à finir les
fins de mois qu'il sacrifie peu à peu
tout d'abord les loisirs puis les soins
et même certaines pour certains d'entre
eux les repas c'est pour eux que nous
avons porté plusieurs pistes
d'amélioration la première reprenait une
vieille promesse du président de la
République 10 fois annoncé 10 fois
enterré le chèque alimentaire nous le
regrettons et nous reviendrons à la
charge car ce dispositif permettait
aussi de soutenir nos agriculteurs qui
ont besoin de notre soutien par contre
nous nous réjouissons que vous ayez
repris notre proposition de cheèque
carburant et d'élargir son périmètre
nous voulions un dispositif simple ciblé
et qui donne un peu d'air à C les ceux
qui voient leurs dépenses contraintte
augmenter désormais les travailleurs
modestes et les classes moyennes qui
utilisent leur voiture pourront toucher
un chèque de 100 € cela ne répondra pas
à tous les problèmes certes mais c'est
un cout de pouce bienvenu au total le
coût de cette mesur d'urgence est près
de 600 millions d'euros et nous sommes
satisfaits d'en avoir ouvert le bénéfice
1,6 millions de Français supplémentaires
nous serons d'ailleurs particulièrement
attentifs à la mise en œuvre de cette
mesure elle devra être simple que tous
en bénéficie et je le dis d'ailleurs aux
Français qui gagneent moins de 1600 €
pour une personne seul et moins de 4800
€ pour un couple avec deux enfants vous
avez le droit à ce chèque carburant
demandez-le et n'hésitez pas à nous dire
si vous rencontrez des difficultés cet
automne nous nous sommes également
mobilisés pour que vous renonciez à la
ponction prévue de laagir Carco cette
mesure ne figurait pas dans ce texte
mais j'y reviens un instant au nom de
notre attachement au paritarisme cœur de
notre modèle social au corps
intermédiaire nous vous avons dit notre
résolution à lutter contre cette
ponction 1 milliard d'euros avec
laquelle vous vouliez financer le
déficit du régime des retraites les
partenaires sociaux ont bien géré laagir
Carco nous estimons que le gouvernement
n'avait pas touché à ses réserves vous
nous avez entendu et les 25 millions de
salariés et de cadres nous suivons de
près le cycle de renégociation avec les
partenaires sociaux avec lesquels nous
sommes en contact régulier nous sommes
aussi
particulièrement heureux de nous être
engager avec d'autres pour mieux
soutenir l'initiative territoire zéro
chômeur qui permet aux chômeurs de
longue durée de retrouver du travail et
de la dignité près de 60 territoires
sont engagés dans cette expérimentation
novatrice il manquait 21 20 millions
d'euros nous en avons arraché 11 je veux
aussi dire un mot pour les petites
améliorations obtenues en direction des
territoires ultramarin la suspension de
la redevance sur l'eau potable à Mayotte
euh le fond de soutien pour les jeunes
entrepreneurs ultramarins pour renforcer
l'aide aux associations sanitaires et
sociales les fonds de secours face aux
catastrophe naturell ce sont des petits
pas qui ne peuvent pas remplacer une
vision une ambition plus globale pour
l'outrem c'est pour ces progrès que nous
ne voterons pas cette motion de censure
cela ne signifie pas que ce budget soit
bon ni que nous voulions conforter la
poursuite du 493 nous souitons au
contraire que vous puissiez gouverner à
avec une autre méthode lorsqu'il est
divisé notre pays est faible en revanche
la France est forte lorsqu'elle sait se
réunir surtout autour d'un projet commun
c'est ici ensemble et avec nos
compatriotes que nous devons réécrire ce
destin commun c'est cette démarche que
porte le groupe
lot je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Mathieu Lefèvre pour le groupe
Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les membres du gouvernement mes chers
collègues je voudrais tout d'abord dire
mon indignation face à la tonalité des
intervention de Monsieur léoman et de
notre collègue des écologistes on peut
être en désaccord avec des politiques
publiques mais on ne peut pas insulter
des femmes et des hommes qui sont issus
d'une histoire politique qui est longue
et et qui nous dépasse et qui
manifestement vous dépasse un petit peu
plus je voudrais vous dire que vous vous
vous rêvez de couper des têtes mais
manifestement je crois que vous avez
perdu la vôtre et il faut que vous
puissiez vous ressaisir et parce que
vous en avez parlé Monsieur léomand je
voudrais vous le dire très clairement il
n'est même plus là pour entendre ces
contradicteures que dimanche la marche
c'est une marche pour la République et
contre l'antisémitisme si on n'y
participe pas c'est qu'on a un problème
à la fois avec la République et à la
fois avec la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme mes chers de la France
insoumise vous avez dépensé ces derniers
jours sans compter et vous venez à
présent vous opposer à la conséquence de
votre propre incue parce que
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement sur la seconde partie du
projet de loi de finances n'est au fond
que la conséquence de de l'embolie
budgétaire à laquelle vous vous êtes
livré vous auriez pu faire tout à fait
autrement vous auriez pu avoir une
attitude digne d'un parti de
gouvernement consistant à opérer des
choix différents dans le respect du
champ du possible budgétaire et vous ne
l'avez pas fait parce qu'au fond vous ne
voulez pas pas de ce sérieux vous ne
voulez pas de la la contrepartie à l'art
de gouverner qui fonde sa crédibilité et
vous rêvez d'une loi de finances qui
efface vos dettes comme une ardoise
magique chaque mission budgétaire mes
chers collègues a été noyée sous une
avalanche de dépenses inconsidérées à
tel point que vous avez dû vous-même
vous censurer dès l'instant où vous avez
vidé les caisses d'un programme
budgétaire en commission des finances le
jour même où la première ministre
présentait un ambitieux conseil
interministériel en faveur de la
politique de la ville vous avez réduit à
zéro les crédits de la politique de la
ville je que les Français doivent savoir
où mènerait votre gestion du pays il
doivent savoir qu'ils ont le choix entre
une majorité qui agit concrètement au
service de leur quotidien et ceux qui
n'ont que faire de l'équilibre de nos
comptes parce que derrière vos dépenses
inconsidérées mes chers collègues il n'y
a que les impôts des Français
d'aujourd'hui ou la dette de demain et
oui nous assumons d'être comptable
comptable pour rendre possible ce que
des générations de politiques n'avait
pas fait avant nous et qu'il propose
aujourd'hui de censurer dans la
grandeoquence de leur de leur opposition
allez comprendre mes chers collègues
pourquoi aujourd'hui les socialistes
proposent de censurer un gouvernement
qui procède à la plus importante
revalorisation salariale de nos
enseignants depuis des décennies un
enseignant touchait 1700 € en début de
carrière en 2017 il touchera aujourd'hui
grâce au président de la République et
grâce à Gabriel hatal 2500 € en début de
carrière moi je crois que dans le fond
ce dont vous avez rêvé nous le faisons
et aujourd'hui dans la grande éloquence
de l'opposition vous préférez faire le
choix de la censure je pense que les
Français s'en souviendront allez
comprendre également pourquoi les
prétendus défenseurs de l'ordre public
du rassemblement national s'apprête à
joindre leur voix au vôtre une nouvelle
fois pour rejeter les meilleurs budgets
en faveur du régalien de la 5e
République après le vote de ce soir moi
je voudrais vous le dire plus aucun de
ceux qui auront inséré un bulletin oui
dans l'urne ne pourront prétendre
défendre nos policiers nos gendarmes nos
militaires nos magistrats nos greffiers
plus aucun de ceuxla ne pourra dire
tranquilleement à ces électeurs j'ai
refusé de voter le doublement des moyens
de nos armées depuis 2017 j'ai refusé de
créer 200 brigades de gendarmerie j'ai
refusé la création de 15000 places de
prisons supplémentaires mais
rassurez-vous je suis du côté de l'ordre
public au moment où notre pays est
menacé dans ces frontières et à
l'extérieur de ces frontières
mes chers collègues écologistes allez
comprendre pourquoi vous censurez le
meilleur budget en faveur de la
transition écologique depuis ces 10
dernières années ces 20 dernières années
40 milliards d'
personne ne l'avait fait est-ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin peut-être très
certainement est-ce qu'il faut pour
autant rejeter cet effort inédit d'un
trait de plume je ne le crois pas est-ce
qu'il faut dire non à l'effort massif
qui est fait en faveur de la rénovation
des bâtiments privés en faveur de nos
écoles en faveur des bâtiments d'État
faut-il mes chers collègues écologistes
sous prétexte que l'inédit n'est pas
assez dire non aux moyens exceptionnells
qui sont consacrés à la protection de
nos forêts à la biodiversité ou encore
au verdissement de notre parc automobile
mobile dans le fond je crains que cette
censure pour laquelle d'ailleurs vous
êtes de moins en moins nombreux présents
à la votere vous n'étiez plus que 89 la
fois précédente consiste en une posture
politique consistante à dire non et
trois fois non à des progrès que les
majorités que vous avez soutenu n'ont
jamais été en mesure de proposer et
c'est là une véritable impasse me
semble-t-il alors oui avec la majorité
autour de la première ministre nous
préférons persévérer du côté de la
responsabilité et mener des tique
publique concrète pour les français
plutôt que de nous enfoncer dans le
double écueil du pas assez et du
toujours plus et nous savons que le
corollaire à ces progrès inédit c'est à
la fois la bonne gestion de nos deniers
publics et la certitude que tout ne
procède pas du hclos de l'État que nous
devons ces progrès collectif aux efforts
des Français qui entreprennent aux
salariés aux professions libérales à nos
agents publics à tous ceux qui croient
dans le pouvoir de transformation du
réelqu travaill et dans lequel vous ne
croyez en aucun
cas savez je je on peut penser que vous
rêvez et même que vous croyez à un monde
sans contrainte un monde dans lequel
l'endettement n'a d'autres limite que
votre imagination dépensière mais
peut-être que votre politique économique
est un peu plus complexe que ça et je
veux bien le croire et de ce point de
vue au travers de vos amendements vous
nêtes au fond pas si mélanchonien que ça
vous ne croyez pas douce que la dette
est un épouvantail qui ne servirait qu'à
faire peur et qu'il suffirait de de ne
pas rembourser parce que sinon on ne
comprend pas que vous cherchiez à
compenser votre frénésie budgétaire par
une frénésie fiscale on comprend pas que
vous cherchiez à compenser le
déséquilibre budgétaire que vous créez
en prétendant que le gouvernement se
priverait à dessin d'un trésor de
recette publique qui refuserait de taxer
ici les milliardaires et là les ouvriers
qui effectue des heures supplémentaires
si la dette n'est véritablement rien
pour vous pourquoi adossez-vous
l'avalangeche de vos dépenses à des
recette mirifique et inexistante c'est
qu'au fond vous avez une forme de
surmois budgétaire vous savez bien que
ça n'est pas ainsi qu'il faut faire et
vous savez bien que l'endettement se
paye toujours d'un prix aujourd'hui du
sérieux budgétaire et demain si vous
étiez en responsabilité de l'austérité
comme ça s'est passé il y a pas si
longtemps mes chers collègues c'était en
Grèce la vérité c'est que vous savez
pertinemment qu'une France qui dépense
l'équivalent de sa richesse nationale
l'équivalent de ce qu'elle produit avec
des cheècs en blanc c'est une France qui
court à sa propre perte et qui court à
sa propre faillite et peut-être dans le
fond que vous vous satisfaisez d'une
France qui en 2 17 dépensera plus pour
rembourser ses créanciers plutôt que
pour financer l'investissement dans la
transition écologique plutôt que pour
préparer l'avenir de nos enfants et ça
n'est pas le choix que nous faisons et
le sérieux budgétaire d'aujourd'hui le
sérieux budgétaire quiincarne ce texte
il a vocation précisément à éviter cet
écueil dans lequel vous voudriez nous
entraîner parce que mes chers collègues
la politique que vous défendez c'est une
politique qui a un nom et qui est très
simple elle s'appelle taxer plus pour
dépenser plus et cette politique on en a
vu les conséquences ces dernières années
et ces conséquences ils ont deux noms
ils s'appellent chômage de masse et
désindustrialisation voilà à quoi
mènerait le budget si nous vous le
confions alors mes chers collègues
autour de la majorité face à cette
politique qui propose une solution
publique et budgétaire à chacun des
problèmes des Français face à cette
politique du chèque permanent face à
votre idéal d'une société faite
d'allocation sans contrepartie nous
opposons une société fondée sur le
travail et la recherche d'une prospérité
collective qui protège les plus
vulnérables et qui agit sur les causes
véritables des dysfonctionnements du
marché plutôt que de refuser d'y
participer et toutes celles et tous ceux
qui ont déjà présidé aux destinés de ce
grand pays le savent dans le secret de
leur conscience une nation dont les
comptes sont en désordrees est une
nation qui s'abandonne et dans le fond
c'est dans le puissant fond de la dette
que se creuse le tombeau des grandes
puissances autour de de la première
ministre et avec la majorité nous
refuserons toujours cette fatalité et
évidemment nous rejetterons cette motion
de
sension merci Monsieur Le
Fèvre la parole est à Monsieur Thomas
ménager pour le groupe rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues il y a 53
ans le 9 novembre 1970 le général de
Gaulle nous quittait ce matin même
j'étais à Colombé les deux églises avec
de nombreux collègu pour honorer la
mémoire de celui qui nous a laissé en
héritage une Constitution dont vous
n'avez eu de cesse madame la Première
ministre de pervertir l'esprit depuis
votre nomination quel contraste entre
cette matinée à Colombé et le retour ce
soir dans cette Assemblée nationale
dépouillé de ses prérogatives empêché de
débattre et de proposer quel contraste
entre le sens des responsabilités de ce
géant de l'histoire de France qui a su
s'élever au-delà des partis et le cinéma
ridicule de votre gouvernement face aux
représentants du peuple comme le disait
le cardinal le cardinal de Richelieu
l'autorité contraint à l'obéissance mais
la raison y persuade depuis le début de
ce second quinquena votre gouvernement a
décidé de s'asseoir sur la volonté des
Français qui en vous mettant minorité à
l'Assemblée nationale et en faisant du
rassemblement national le premier parti
d'opposition vous envoyez un message
très clair loin d'entendre les
préoccupations des Français vous usez de
la contrainte face à votre incapacité à
mettre en place la coconstruction que
vous prétendez appeler de vos vœux loin
d'être doté de la sage et nécessaire
autorité évoquée par Richelieu vous
faites peser sur la représentation
nationale une autorité procédurale
froide technique celle du 493 qui vous
colle aux mains comme le pr et
l'arrogance colle à la peau d'Emmanuel
Macron je l'ai dit nous commémorons
aujourd'hui le décès de celui qui avec
Michel Debray a doté la France d'une
constitution qui entendé faire du peuple
le véritable sou véritable souverain
excusez-moi et non pas le
493 j'aimerais insister sur ce point
madame la Première ministre l'outil
constitutionnel qui est le 493 n'a pas
été pensé dans le but de museler les
oppositions mais pour ressouder une
majorité que vous n'avez pas si vous ne
souhaitez pas débattre avec vos
oppositions élu par les Français alors
il serait sage de convoquer à nouveau
les Français dans les urnes c'est ce
qu'a fait le général de Gaulle en son
temps porté par le courage qui
caractérise l'action de ces grands
hommes d'État qui ont marqué la France
qui imagine un gouvernement sous le
général de Gaulle engager sa
responsabilité pour la 16e fois en 18
mois sans jamais se remettre en question
au fond vous avez peur peur du débat
peur des Français peur de la
contradiction à milieu de tout
changement de cap vous justifiez ce
nouveau passage en force en mobilisant
les pires mensonges en déclenchant ce
16e 493 vous avez déclaré madame la
Première ministre je cite nous ne
pouvons pas priver la France d'un budget
à vous entendre faute de majorité
absolue le 493 serait inéluctable pour
pouvoir payer nos fonctionnaires ou
faire fonctionner nos hôpitaux même si
vous vivez dans le délire de la startup
nation sachez qu'en France il n'y a pas
de shutdown à l'américaine et vous le
savez très madame la Première ministre
notre Constitution est très bien faite
elle prévoit justement un dispositif
permettant en l'absence de vote de faire
entrer en vigueur le budget par
ordonnance afin d'assurer la continuité
de la vie de la nation en aucun cas la
France ne pourrait être un jour privée
de budget rien ne justifiait donc
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement quelques heures seulement
après le début des débats sur cette 2è
partie du projet de loi de finances de
la même manière vu que nous en sommes à
évoquer les mensonges je souhaite
répondre ce soir à Madame lovagie des
républicains qui se cache derrière son
petit doigt en permanence en déformant
la Constitution pour faire croire que
voter une motion de censure créerait de
facto un gouvernement alternatif composé
de l'ensemble des oppositions ayant voté
la motion de censure vous le savez
madame lovagie il s'agit simplement de
forcer la démission de madame la
Première ministre et quelle tristesse de
vous voir Madame lovagie travestir la
Constitution le jour anniversaire de la
mort de son fondateur et si ça peut vous
rassurer madame lovagie parce que je
sens que vous êtes inquiète je peux vous
dire que après avoir écouté monsieur
léomand qui est déjà parti à la buvette
sûrement ce Robespierre acheté sur wish
jamais le rassemblement national je vous
le dis jamais le rassemblement national
ne sallira avec les partisans du chaos
les partisans du Hamas les partisans de
la France insoumise mais madame la
Première ministre il est bien pratique
de votre côté de vous cacher derrière un
prétendu esprit de responsabilité pour
éviter tout débat et avaliser votre
budget sans prendre en compte les
propositions des députés d'opposition
qui sont bien souvent le relais de ce
que les Français attendent d'un budget
plus de sécurité des services publics
plus efficaces ou encore une attention
particulière pour nos compatriotes les
plus fragiles en réalité les Français ne
sont pas dupes ils ont bien compris que
vous ne cherchez jamais aucun compromis
préférant une conception très étroite du
débat démocratique et une pratique du
pouvoir de plus en plus contestable
allant jusqu'à écarter totalement avec
ces 493 des amendement pourtant voté par
la représentation nationale à la fois en
commission et en séance contrairement à
ce que vous indiquez le budget que vous
nous imposé aujourd'hui né en rien un
budget de responsabilité avec votre
budget la France va devoir lever
285 milliards d'euros d'endettement pour
financer son déficit et une dette àysal
qui atteint près de 110 % du PIB avec
votre budget les impôts vont bondir de
17 milliards d'euros et le taux de
prélèvement obligatoire va encore
augmenter par rapport à 2023 avec votre
budget le déficit public sera de 4,4 %
du PIB soit 145 milliards d'euros ce qui
représente l'ensemble des recette de
l'impôt sur le revenu et de l'impôt sur
les sociétés avec votre budget encore ce
sont 61 milliards d'euros des impôts des
Français qui paieront la seule charge de
la dette soit plus que les budgets
consacrés à la défense à la sécurité et
juste avant l'éducation je pense que ces
chiffres désastreux devrai vous obliger
un peu de modestie madame la Première
ministre le gouvernement présente pour
la 50e année consécutive un budget en
déficit et comme l'a très bien dit mon
collègue Jean-Philippe Tangui si en
mariage ce serait les no d'or avec vous
ce sont les nos de plomb comment
pouvez-vous encore vous targuer de la
bonne tenue des comptes publics comment
pouvez-vous encore appeler les
oppositions à la responsabilité quand
vous n'assumez pas les votes et les
faites peser sur les Français par un
niveau inédit de pression fiscale vous
aviez promis près de 4 milliards d'euros
d'économie qu'en est-il réellement le
projet de loi de finances de fin gestion
révèle par ailleurs que pour 2023 les
crédits alloués au service de la dette
doivent augmenter de 3,8 milliards
d'euros car Bery a fait une erreur de
calcul nul doute que les experts sont
encore une fois à la manœuvre notre
collègue Kevin mauvieux rapporteur
spécial de la commission des finances
sur cette question n'a pourtant cessé de
vous alerter dès le mois de juin il
dénonçait la charge excessive de la
dette que vous alloudissez année après
année et qui pèsera sur nos enfants dès
le mois de juin il dénoncait les
mécanismes d'indexation de la dette sur
inflation les fameuses OATi la dette
atteint donc des niveaux jamais vus
auparavant vous cramez donc la caisse de
façon totalement irresponsable sur le
dos du contribuable mais posons-nous la
question que vient donc financer cette
dette attaché à la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques les députés du rassemblement
national ont dénoncé les nombreuses
dépenses inutiles superflues excessives
à l'occasion des examens budgétaire en
commission permettez-moi de revenir sur
certaines d'entre elles près de 80
millions milliard d'euros sont donnés
aux opérateurs et aux agences de l'État
en réduisant leur budget de 10 % c'est
près de 8 milliards d'euros qui pourrai
être rendu aux Français comme l'indique
la Cour des comptes dans ses derniers
rapports près de 20 milliards 21
milliards d'euros sont versés à l'Union
européenne qui demande d'ailleurs une
rallonge pour mieux payer ses
fonctionnaires alors que eux les
Français sont contraints de se serrer la
ceinture si ce budget est en baisse de
manière opportune étrangement à
l'approche des élections européennes il
augmentera à nouveau pour atteindre 27
milliards en 2025 au rassemblement
national nous proposons d'économiser 5
milliards d'euros en ramenant notre
contribution nette au niveau connu sous
le mandat de Jacques Chirac qui n'était
pas vous le l'avourez pourtant réputé
pour être un anti-européen ensuite ce
sont près de 2 millions d'euros qui sont
versés chaque année à votre ministère
monsieur verrand que ce soit pour
financer vos micro trottoirs ou faire
votre campagne de propagande contre le
rassemblement national ou encore comme
vous l'avez fait ces derniers jours pour
tenir des propos scandaleux des propos
scandaleux à l'encontre de l'unité
nationale que les Français attendent
comp tenu du contexte je suis convaincu
que le référendum serait un outil moins
coûteux et plus efficace pour assurer le
prétendu renouveau démocratique vendu
par votre
ministère enfin en matière migratoire
l'aide médicale d'État au clandestin
augmente encore cé tandis que près d'un
milliard d'euros est versé à des
associations prigrants parmi ces
associations la SIMAD qui intervient
dans centres de rétention administrative
et dont la mobilisation de ses membres a
malheureusement permis aux terroristes
ayant assassiné Dominique Bernard de se
maintenir sur le sol français ce
maintien sur le sol a été aussi possible
grâce au soutien des partis de l'extrême
gauche doublement complice à la fois par
leur soutien actif à la submersion
migratoire et leur contribution
insidieuse à la montée de l'islamiste
radical en
France même Didier lesqui directeur
général de l'OFI qui n'est pas connu
pour être un partisan du rassemblement
national déploré récemment que ces
associations comme la simade ne
répondent pas au Cay descharges de
l'État et que leurs membres agissent
contre les politiques publiques en
matière d'immigration on retrouve aussi
France Terre d'Asile etcoalia dirigé par
des élus de laanupes ou encore écoalist
dont le président se rémunéré à hauteur
de 18000 € par mois et roulé en audit Q8
au frais du
contribuable autant de dépenses
extravagantes qui pourrait être une base
d'économie dans le budget de l'État le
coup près du 493 nous empêche
malheureusement de les soumettre au vote
de la représentation nationale ensuite
si l'État dépense trop il dépense
surtout très mal cette année encore
l'état n'est pas au rendez-vous pour nos
collectivités locales qui subissent de
plein fouet l'inflation l'association
des mares de France dénonce même votre
budget comme un nouveau supplice du
garot la DGF Stein tout comme les
dotations spécifiques à destination des
territoires ruraux mais dans le même
temps vous abondez pourtant un fond
violent surbine visant à réparer les
dégâts des émeutes au frais du
contribuable plutôt qu'au frais des
casseurs votre gouvernement avait promis
en grande pompe d'accompagner les
collectivités face à la hausse des
dépenses énergétiques a avec le fameux
filet de sécurité mais voilà que vous
demandez maintenant à plus de 3400
collectivités de rembourser les accomtes
véritable coup de Massu pour les maires
des petites communes rurales qui ne
cachent pas leur incompréhension et leur
colère face à ce dispositif et ces
méthodes opaques je pense aussi à ces
familles à ces femmes à ces hommes à ces
jeunes que je reçois chaque semaine dans
ma permanence à montargie et qui se
sentent méprisés et abandonnés face à
l'absence de services publics d'aesh ou
encore de structures pouvant accueillir
les victimes de violence conjugale
j'avais d'ailleurs soumis un amendement
proposant d'accompagner la création d'un
logement d'urgence pour les victimes de
violence conjugale dans chaque
intercommunalité particulièrement en
milieu rural où il n'y en a pas nous
n'avons malheureusement pas pu en
débattre ayant été privé de la
possibilité d'examiner en commission des
lois les crédits dédiés aux relations de
l'État avec les collectivités
territoriales comment enfin ne pas
penser à nos compatriotes d'outremère
qui souffent depuis des années de
l'inaction de de l'État que ce soit en
matière d'immigration massive d'accès à
certaines infrastructures d'accès à
l'eau ou encore à la présence de
bidonville sur ces parties de notre
territoire national notre collègue
Johann Gillet rapporteur spécial de la
commission des lois a pu en rendre
compte dans son rapport c'est quelques
exemples illustrent à quel point votre
budget est déconnecté des attentes de
nos compatriotes députés du
rassemblement national nous avons été à
nouveau force de proposition en
présentant près de 1200 amendements
tirés notamment du projet de Marine Le
Pen qui faut-il le rappeler est l'une
des seules candidates à l'élection
présidentielle à avoir présenté au
français un chiffrage précis de ces
propositions des mesures concrètes pour
remettre de l'ordre dans nos comptes en
réduisant le train de vie de l'État et
les dépenses superflues et cela afin de
financer tout d'abord une politique de
justice sociale qui ne laisse aucun
Français sur le côté avec des mesures
efficaces comme la baisse de la TVA sur
l'énergie et les carburants alors que
vous faites-vous madame la Première
ministre le choix d'augmenter le GNR qui
va pénaliser nos agriculteurs nos
pêcheurs et le secteur du BTP nos
économies financeront également une
politique de sécurité plus que jamais
attendu par les Français face à la
montée de la violence du fondamentalisme
islamisme mais aussi des actes
antisémites qui explosent dans notre
pays madame la Première ministre vous ne
semblez ce soir ni paniqué ni même
inquiète de voir votre gouvernement
renverser en raison de la duplicité des
républicains qui mettent en scène leur
opposition à votre budget mais qui une
fois encore sont absents sauf madame
lovagie la courageuse qui sont ce soir
absents pour sanctionner vos méthodes et
votre manque d'ambition pour notre pays
dans un régime parlementaire en bonne
santé madame la Première ministre le
peuple et ses représentants votent et
expriment leur désaccords sur les textes
dans le régime fatigué qui est le vôtre
et que vous vous plaisez à abîmer chaque
jour davantage le seul moyen d'exprimer
ces désaccords est maintenant de voter
des motions de censure par votre mépris
du débat parlementaire vous faites vôre
les propos de Cano de bergera qui disait
que c'est bien plus beau lorsque c'est
inutile nous rassemblement national nous
nous sommes engagés pour être utiles
pour protéger les Français c'est
pourquoi malgré les outrances permanen
de l'extrême gauche dont monsieur léom
nous a fait une nouvelle démonstration
ce soir et parce que nous sommes animés
par le seul intérêt général nous
voterons ce soir la censure de votre
gouvernement merci Monsieur
ménager la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas
duponignan en sa qualité de député non
inscrit
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre chers collègues ce soir je vais
vous surprendre peut-être mais je ne
vais pas m'adresser à vous madame la
Première ministre ni à votre
gouvernement mais à mes collègues
députés des oppositions et je veux leur
dire trois choses très simples
premièrement nous sommes tous d'accord
je pense députés d'opposition des
oppositions sur ces bancs pour affirmer
que le bilan de votre gouvernement est
désastreux explosion de l'insécurité
déficit budgétaires et commerciaux à
Bisso baisse du pouvoir d'achat
augmentation de la pauvreté
accroissement des injustice et
aujourd'hui malheureusement en plus
perte totale de crédibilité de la
politique étrangère de la
France deuxièmement nous sommes tous
d'accord aussi je crois sur
l'impossibilité de laisser notre
gouvernement piétiner notre démocratie
encore 3 ans et demi comment mes chers
collègues imaginez l'adoption chaque
année des budgets de l'État ou de la
sécurité sociale par des 493 en
rafale même au sein de votre minorité
présidentielle des voix s'inquiètent de
la réaction possible des Français face à
ces passages en force
permanen si nous sommes donc si nous
sommes donc tous d'accord sur le
caractère catastrophique du bilan de
votre gouvernement si nous sommes tous
aussi d'accord sur le fait que nous ne
pouvons pas le laisser gouverner contre
le peuple jusqu'en 2027 au risque
d'ailleurs d'une réaction de la rue
naturellement nous serons tous d'accord
pour conclure qu'il faut voter la
censure mais alors mes chers collègues
pourquoi les oppositions ne sont-elles
pas capablees
de la voter ensemble j'entends toujours
le même refrain digne d'une cour de
récréation nous ne pouvons pas nous
associer ici avec le rassemblement
national nous ne pouvons pas voter là
avec LFI mes chers collègues ouvrez les
yeux cet argument n'est pas valable car
une motion de censure ne peut aboutir
par principe que par une conjonction des
oppositions c'est évident ve ensemble sû
ne signifie en rien que ces oppositions
vot gouverneront demain ensemble votez
la censure c'est
obliger le président de la République
soit changer de gouvernement pour
changer de politique soit à dissoudre
pour permettre aux Français de choisir
eux-mêmes l'autre politique qu'il
souhaite c'est au peuple et c'est ce
qu'avait prévu le général de Gaulle
c'est au peuple de trancher le conflit
de légitimité entre d'un côté le
président élu et de mois après seulement
cette assemblée élue qui refuse de vous
donner les moyens d'appliquer votre
politique et heureusement chaque député
d'opposition a donc ce soir comme aux
précédentes motions de censure et sans
doute au prochaine une responsabilité
écrasante devant l'histoire de grâce
députés républicains vous ne pouvez pas
faire semblant quand même d'être des
opposants devant les caméras de
télévision tout en disparaissant de
l'hémicycle lors du vote de la censure
20 fois je suis très sérieux 20 fois
vous avez déclaré à la presse que vous
alliez déposer une motion censure 20
fois vous avez abandonner vos électeurs
mais quand allez-vous mettre en
cohérence votre discours de opposition
et vos actes au moins Nicolas Sarkozy
est cohérent il veut rejoindre la
majorité mais vous vous faites semblant
l'opposition mais vous sauvez le
gouvernement à chaque fois député du
groupe
Lott vous avez donné un espoir aux
Français lors de l'indigne réforme des
retraites mais que s'est-il passé depuis
6 mois pourquoi avez-vous renoncé à
voter les censures des négociations ici
ou là député de
LFI soyez cohérents si vous voulez que
les autres groupes votent vos motions de
censure ne rejetez pas les leurs par
sectarisme quand ils en déposent ne
soyez pas comme au second tour de la
présidentielle les idiots utiles
d'Emmanuel Macron
alors les choses sont claires en
multipliant les
493 le gouvernement croit nous
lasser mais vous n'imaginez pas chers
collègues de l'opposition des
oppositions la frustration que vous
créez chez nos concitoyens et la grave
crise institutionnelle que vous
nourrissez en ne vous mettant pas
d'accord ici et maintenant pour censurer
ce gouvernement qui fait tant de mal au
français il en va de l'avenir de la
France je vous
remercie la parole est maintenant à
madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous
plaît s'il vous
plaît
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Députés il est déjà bien tard ce jeudi
soir l'émicyque est clair semé pour
débattre de cette 24e motion de censure
la 7è en moins de 2
mois aussi je me contenterai de quelques
messages d'abord pour revenir sur
l'utilisation frénéthtique des motions
de censure par
certains samedi dernier dans leurs
interventions les députés senseurs ont
eux-mêmes fait un aveu éloquant son
déposé je cite bien trop de motions de
censure leur faisant ainsi perdre ce
caractère d'exception qui est pourtant
leur fonction petit à petit plus rien
n'a de poids plus rien n'a de valeur ni
de sens je ne pensais pas citer la
députée sandine Sandrine Rousseau à la
tribune mais ce constat me rassure d'une
certaine manière vous êtes conscient des
conséquences de vos actes de 1988 à
1993 Michel Rocard éedit cresson et
Pierre bergovois n'avaient pas de
majorité absolue pour les mêmes raisons
que nous aujourd'hui
ils ont dû recourir au 493 pour
permettre l'adoption de leur
budget peut-être ces noms vous
parlent-il monsieur l'orateur du groupe
socialiste sur leur projet de bois de
finance la responsabilité des trois
gouvernements a été engagé à 17 reprises
en réponse combien de motions de censure
5 l'opposition était-elle moins
vigoureuse à l'époque je ne le crois pas
la démocratie parlementaire S est-elle
plus mal porté assurément pas au
contraire si nous utilisons le 493
conformément à son esprit pour éviter le
blocage du pays en cas d'absence de
majorité vous
dénaturez pardon pardon s'il vous plaît
mes chers collègues est-ce qu'on peut
respecter la première ministre qui
intervient tout de
[Musique]
même c'est la dernière fois que je dis
hein c'est la dernière fois que je dis
madame la Première ministre pouvez
poursuivre si nous utilisons le 493
conformément à son esprit pour éviter le
blocage du pays en cas d'absence de de
majorité vous dénaturez l'usage
d'émotions de censure la censure réflexe
marque la fin de la censure politique
puisqueavec vous tout est censure tout
ce vaut et plus rien n'a de sens même
les mots n'ont plus de sens quand
l'orateur de la France insoumise osile
entre le ridicule et le dérisoire entre
des mots trop grands pour lui et des
références qui
l'écrasent mais je vous le dis avec
gravité ce soir vous avez franchi des
lignes que je ne croyais pas imaginbl
dans cet hémicycle Louis X la nuit de
Christal je n'ai pas d'autre mot que
celui d'ind des sens comment ici peuton
un outil constitutionnel à la nuit de
Cristal savez-vous de quoi vous parlez
monsieur le
député sans doute une fois encore cela
vous permet-il de jouer avec des lignes
bien floues dans votre rapport à
l'antisémitisme pour revenir à votre
motion on pourrait penser qu'elle sert
au moins à afficher votre unité à
montrer que la P était une alliance de
conviction et non un calcul purement
électoral mais aujourd'hui plus aucun
doute n'est permis et le nombre de
signataires de cette motion est une
nouvelle preuve de vos
divisions mais je veux bien reconnaître
au moins une vertu à vos motions de
censure
elles vous ont déjà rappelé à 15
reprises que vous étiez minoritair elles
vous ont rappelé que vous aviez perdu
les élections législatives elles vous
ont rappelé que vous n'aviez aucune
majorité altern
et et gouverner le
pays j'ajoute que j'ai du mal à recevoir
des leçons de démocratie de la part d'un
groupe qui
s j'ajoute que j'ai du mal à recevoir
des leçons de démocratie de la part d'un
groupe qui sanctionne ses membres pour
délit d'opinion et muselle toute
contradiction tout débat en
son mesames etessieurs
lesputés adresser c'est que nous sommes
capables de bâtir des
compromis sur les 52 textes adoptés
définitivement monsieur de s'il vous
plaît qu'est-ce que j'ai dit il y a
quelques minutes s'il vous plaît oui non
mais
d'accord peut-être monsieur le député
n'a pas noté que nous avons adopté
définitivement 52 textes et sur ces 52
textes définitivement adoptés depuis 1
an et demi par le Parlement se TR seul
trois seul trois on pourrait parler de
la loi de programmation militaire de la
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur de la loi de
programmation de la justice on pourrait
les parler de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage on pourrait parler de la loi
industrie verte je pense que ce sont des
textes importants monsieur le
député donc sur les 52 textes adoptés
définitivement depuis un an et demi par
le Parlement seul trois ont exigé le
recours au 4 493 pour 49 textes nous
avons été en mesure de construire des
accords comme les Français nous l'ont
demandé bien sûr je comprends la
spécificité des budgets pour les groupes
d'opposition mais je ne désespère pas
hier vous avez examiné le projet de loi
de fin de gestion et je veux remercier à
cet égard le travail accompli par le
ministre chargé des comptes publics
Thomas knav et par le rapporteur général
du budget Jean-René
casenu c'est un projet de loi important
il permet des investissements
supplémentaires notamment pour nos
opérations extérieures pour accélérer la
reconstruction après les violences
urbaine de cet été pour notre soutien à
l'Ukraine ou encore pour mieux
indemniser nos agriculteurs face aux
crises sur ce texte nous avons été
capable de discuter de nous entendre et
il a été adopté hier soir en première
lecture mesdames et messieurs les
députés mon troisème et dernier message
est plutôt un étonnement une for de
perplexité je m'interroge sur le rapport
particulièrement troublé
qu'entretiennent les députés sensur
notamment ceux de la France insoumise
avec la
vérité cet étonnement n'est pas récent
j'en conviens mais vous ne reculez
devant rien dans votre motion de censure
comme dans toutes les précédentes vous
recopiez inlassablement le mot
austérité nous navons clairement pas la
même
définition le budget que je défends avec
mon gouvernement ce sont des
investissement majeur c'est 40 milliards
d'euros pour accélérer la transition
écologique c'est près de 2300 postes de
policiers et gendarmes créé l'année
prochaine c'est une augmentation de
moitié du budget de la justice par
rapport à 2017 c'est la création d'une
aide universelle d'urgence pour les
victimes de violence conjugale c'est une
nouvelle augmentation de la DGF pour les
collectivités et grâce à vous grâce à
vos amendements ven de la majorité comme
des oppositions ce budget ce sont aussi
des mesures supplémentaires en faveur
des outrmers des mesures pour permettre
à 60 % des Français qui travaillent de
toucher l'indemnité carburant pour mieux
lutter contre le harcèlement scolaire
pour renforcer notre lutte contre la
pauvreté pour prévenir davantage les
risques causés par la pollution ou
encore pour augmenter les moyens de la
recherche contre les cancers
pédiatriques alors notre budget ce sont
des solutions et des invest
en revanche quand je lis votre motion de
censure et les hausses d'impôts majeurs
que vous réclamez notamment pour les
ménages je peux l'affirmer l'austérité
c'est
vous mesdames et messieurs les
députés mesdames et messieurs les
députés ce budget nous donne les moyens
nécessaires pour toutes nos politiques
publiques il tient notre promesse de ne
pas augmenter les impôts il assure notre
souveraineté en maîtrisant N dépenses
publiques c'est un budget au service des
Français avec mon gouvernement je suis
fier de le porter je vous
remercie merci madame la Première
ministre la discussion est close je vais
maintenant mettre au voie la motion de
censure déposée par Madame Mathilde pano
et 67 membres de l'Assemblée le scrutin
est annoncé dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale je rappelle que
seul les députés favorables à la motion
participent au scrutin et que le vote se
déroule dans les salles voisines de
l'hémicycle le scrutin va donc être
ouvert pour 20 minutes il sera clos à
minuit 17 la séance est suspendue la
séance est reprise voici le résultat du
scrutin majorité requise pour l'adoption
de la motion de censure soit la majorité
absolue des membres composant
l'assemblée 289 pour l'adoption
167 la majorité requise n'étant pas
atteinte la motion de censure n'est pas
adoptée en conséquence la seconde partie
est l'ensemble du projet de loi de
finances pour 2024 sont considérés comme
adopté prochaine séance lundi 13 octobre
à 16h lecture définitive du projet de
loi programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023-227 proposition de
loi relative à la restitution des restes
humains appartenant aux collections
publiques deè lecture de la proposition
de loi visant à mieux protéger et
accompagner les enfants victimes et
covictimes de violence intrafamilial et
proposition loi visant à revaloriser le
métier de secrétaire de mairie la séance
est levée